Uh, dude, it like Willie to report Destiny, didn't it? Willie
looks so depressed making that phone call. That was like the
worst day of his life. Okay, easily the worst day of his life.
Whatever. Like 17, 18. Here's the thing, okay? When it comes
to ages for hooking up, like regardless of how far you want to
go, 18 and older is an adult in the United States. If people
are like, "Oh, you should wait until they're 21." Then I feel
like it would just move to 21 and older. Like, oh, why are you
hooking up with a 21-year-old? Or why you hooking up with a 23-y
old? Listen,
age is just a number, guys.
He's he's just totally uh blurring the lines here, right? The
the allegation is after you had reason to believe you had some
suspicion that she was a minor, you then shared artifacts from
the CSAM she sent you, from the potential seam she sent you,
that you shared with other people in order to try to find her,
right?
chill.
Oh, let me pull this cleaning tweet up,
dude. You wouldn't believe it. Okay, hold on. This is Destiny
talking about Willax's wife. Oh, I should go through all of this
actually. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, cuz I believe I
believe Nicholas got mad about this. Hold on. Let me pull the
Nicholas tweet up.
Let me pull it up. Let me pull it up. Is it Nicholas saying that
this is Destiny attacking? Yeah, Destiny is now targeting at
Willie Mac Show's wife.
Oh, you you guys care about Destiny targeting people's significant
others now. Is that something we actually pretend to care about?
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Let's read Let's read the comments here and see how badly Destiny
is attacking Willy Mack's wife.
When I was in Israel a year and a half ago, the MSAD did actually
want to hire me for propaganda, but I said it would be way too
obvious. They offered me a cutie pie in exchange for it, but
I said my Viveance arc made me made it not appealing. I didn't
want to say anything, but I noticed that exact same Israeli agent
they were offering me just so happens to be Willy's new wife.
I don't want to leak this, but now I will, I guess. Oh, sorry.
I It was top to bottom, but Right.
I'm sorry. You can hate Destiny as much you as you want. That's
clearly a joke. He's clearly not actually attacking anybody.
This is just a This is just a meme. This is obviously just a
meme. And they go, "Oh, Destiny's now attacking Willie Mo's wife."
Bro, come on. You can't You can't flip this hard when somebody
like says something about you when you guys go this hard that
hard on everybody else. Okay. When that's like a clear joke.
Oh, it's a cutie pie. Don't worry about it. I'm just telling
you that's clearly a joke. You look supery. You just give Desi
like it out. You look supery there. No, Zezy. You can you can
load this as much as you want. It's still just incredibly soy.
It's incredibly soy to to Zoy out about this. It is. It is. It
is.
But Queenman comes in with the uh everything Destiny is saying
here is true. Lol. Which makes it so much better. Okay, that
makes it so much
doesn't it? Everybody understands the reference. Everything Desty
says is saying here is true. Lol.
We remember.
Now, you don't have to believe me, okay? You don't have to believe
me, but I swear to God, I I told Jerry, I said, I wish Nicholas
didn't have me blocked so I can go and reply to this with the
Willie Mac Show tweet, right? I wanted to go do that. I said
this and then I said, I'll just I'm just going to go tweet it
anyway. I'll just like take a picture. And I walked over to my
computer and refreshed Twitter and 3 seconds, okay, it was like
a 5-second old tweet from Queenman was this. I was like, you
piece of you, you beat me. Beat me by like 5 seconds. All right.
Was up. He's in your walls. Many such cases. Many such cases.
I was I was just a funny little thing that I was like, "Oh,
it's just a good tweet. Just a good tweet. That's all."
we're rolling. We're rolling. We're rolling. Where are we headed
first? We all joked about this one last night, guys. Okay, we
all joked about this last night. All right. Destiny goes to DG
DG chat last night and says, "I'm just done talking about everything
until the case is over. There's literally zero reason to do it.
Either bad faith actors in the juice or KF community will try
to weaponize everything or trying to virtue signal like Willie
Mack and Ethan will just try to demonstrate their virtue to people.
I'm just done commenting. He says before spending the entire
night commenting, the entire next day commenting, right? Like
who who do you think you're fooling, bro? Who do you think you're
actually fooling when you say this? We all know that you're not
going to stop. We all know that you're incapable of stopping,
right? We know that you're incapable of stopping.
Why lie to yourself? Q. Seven tweets, 24 replies, 96 blocks,
and 40 minutes on stream. Yeah, exactly. Sorry, we're getting
some tweets in as well. Years ago, Destiny was friends with super
famous mainstream Twitch streamers like Pokémon and Lily Pichu.
These days, he talks to food shops offream. Hey, just a year
ago, he had connections to Ben Shapiro, Tim P, Candace Owens,
whole bunch of major political commentators.
What happened to that, too?
Destiny Food Chops looking at evidence
bro. What do you think? Food Do you think he was linking?
We all thought he was linking the transcript. Maybe he was linking
something Food Chops was much more interested in. Who knows?
Who knows? Now, I I'm not making a claim there. Okay, I'm just
I'm just hypothesizing. I'm just asking questions. Okay, I'm
just asking questions. That's all. That's all. That's all. That's
all. All right. So, we had we had this this is uh Substance.
I believe it's simply substance in in chat here, right? I believe
this is the same substance.
Simp simply substance in the chat. He he tweeted this and he
posted this last night, I believe, as well. A couple people were
posting this just like there's no way. And of course,
last night, Destiny did go and make multiple comments. Okay,
after that, after that, he went to the YouTube video for Ethan
Klein.
Okay. Ethan Klein's YouTube video on Destiny and says, "Insane
to see the guy spamming lawsuits at people reading a totally
unrelated set of DMs pretending they were the to the same person.
I've never contacted the Rose person on IG at any point in my
life, but this guy and his suckup crew are just chuckling along
as they read off leaked revenge on me." Very high moral standards,
I guess. Or just desperately trying to cater to the audience.
Z.
So, Destiny drops that comment on the YouTube video. I believe
Ethan Klein's first response is actually fairly reasonable. Do
I have Ethan Klein's first response here? Yeah. Yeah. Oh, hold
on. I don't have it. Hold on. I'll grab it real quick. Ethan's
first response, I believe, is something along the lines of uh
if I got something wrong, feel free to point it out. I believe
that's what it is, if I'm not mistaken.
Let me see if I can grab it here. I don't have it. It's something
along the lines of, "Hey, if I got something wrong, then you
feel free to correct it, but like I don't think I got too much
wrong here. If I got a lot wrong, go ahead." Right. Destiny's
focused on these DMs, which were highlighted at the very end,
right? Oh, chuckling along as they read off of leaked revenge
for me. Very high moral standards, I guess. Dude, this this kind
of annoys me when he talks about leaked revenge, right? When
he talks about leaked, when he has leaked on other people multip
I believe multiple times. No. Like, did he not leak those denim
sex? I I don't know how he could get off leaking those denim
sex and then saying, "Oh, this is leaked revenge for me when
it goes to those DMs from the British person." But this is him
responding in the YouTube comment. Okay,
there's a couple things going on around this. All right, couple
things going on. Oh, this got deleted. No way. I believe his
unpopular opinion. I believe this is somebody basically defending
Destiny. Hold on. Anyway, we go we go back and forth. Ethan Klein
posts some responses. Okay. Says, "Hey, go ahead. Show me what
I got wrong." Right. Oh, hold on. We don't go back and forth
yet. We don't go back and forth because I forgot Destiny last
night. Oh, I'm forgetting the time progression. Okay. Oh, boy.
Destiny last night decided to throw this this across the bow
at Ethan. Okay, this is the crazy one. This is much longer. Crazy.
I mean, there are some jokes in here. It's a mix. He is obviously
angry at Ethan, right? Obviously really Ethan. He had an understanding.
Okay. He had an understanding with Ethan. Hey, Ethan. We're going
to totally pretend that like all criticism we're just going to
lump that all in with snarkers, right? We're both going to do
that and then we won't ever call each other out for like for
trying to use this snark community to to silence all criticism
against us. We're both going to do it. We have an understanding,
right? And then Ethan totally took some stuff from Destiny Alogs
and was presenting it because it's facts, right? The facts about
Rose are there. It's it's she was 17 and Ethan used it and Destiny
feels betrayed. They had an understanding. Okay. All snark posting.
All snark is bad. All snark is evil. So the first two sentences
full on admitting he had CP in his possession. No way. Almost
everything in this DM is wrong. Willie Mac is running cover.
I think he means uh Oh, hold on. This goes back to this, right?
Almost everything in this DM. >> Oh, right. This is the
first one. This is the first response. >> This is the first
donated $5. I realized he's
because he's relying on his attorney's advice, but they only
advise him on the narrow purview of the Pixie case. He likely
has no criminal attorney advice with some impossibility. He is
too
one to
>> um No, I think he could easily ask those lawyers for
advice. I think he did ask for advice from those lawyers or his
lawyers in New York, whichever ones. But I believe he left out
the the fact that it was potential cam because otherwise I assume
we would have seen some action there, right? That's that's just
facts. Thanks for the five though. So this was this is the one.
So, is the claim that the DMs are yours but with someone other
than Rose? Do you deny having a 17-year-old's nudes on your computer?
And he says almost everything in these DMs is a lie. Almost everything
in this DM is wrong. Willy Mack is running cover because he wants
to get in with the boys again. 911. Sorry, let me call back.
My OBS wasn't recording. Lol. It is a little weird.
It is a little weird that
that call is recorded. I I guess. But
it it is what it is. It's a YouTuber. Okay. It's a YouTuber.
>> Uh, Funky Boss, thank you for the 16 months.
Is there like some concern there that I don't know. I
never mind. It's fine. It's fine. I won't comment too much on
it. So, sorry. Let me My OBS wasn't recording. Please call me
back. And Ethan is trying to distance himself from me because
he's too weak to deal with Hassan's attacks against him, using
me as a vector since he has literally nothing of substance to
contribute in this area. Hassan's lack of intelligence is his
biggest insecurity that no amount of finasteride, hair dye, or
bathtub photo shoot will compensate for.
Okay. Um,
just seething about Hassan having a full head of hair and
Hassan literally keeps the gray in, right? So, full head of hair
and his GQ just openly seething, transparently seething about
Hassan,
right?
Like there's just there's no actual criticism here. Hzan's Hzan's
not that smart. And and
he he cares about his appearance. What a loser.
>> Uh Downey, thank for the seven months. Let's go. I have
no CSAM on my computer. I've only compiled or sorry, I've only
complied with my legal obligations for my court cases. The 60
GB was related to a claim the Rose person made. Someone whose
name and birth date have yet to even be reliably confirmed.
No, they have been reliably confirmed. They've been reliably
confirmed at this point,
right? Absolutely they have.
60 GB screen was related to a claim the Rose person made. Yes.
So, this is of course him trying to claw on to the idea. I think
we described this yesterday, guys. The 60 GB number that is pointless,
right? This is a pointless number to focus on. You shouldn't
focus on it. What you should focus on is that Destiny appears
to have taken a
from VC media player of what he is saying must be seam, right?
what we now know must be cessam and he sends that to willymac
that is the concerning thing he's done right
I don't have cam on my computer I believe what he's saying Ozel
is that he has archived it and held it in in hard drives somewhere
else or something right I think that's what he's saying now unfortunately
him holding it on his own has led to him sending uh like archives
like artifacts of that cessam to other people seems like he's
admitted this
very bad very not good right but he's trying to focus on the
60 gig thing because he he's pretending that makes a big difference,
right? This is why you should try to focus on the most important
questions. Destiny, did you in fact send artifacts of this child
abuse material to a group chat of 10 people trying to find the
person who you didn't believe was a minor, but had had reason
to be at least minorly suspicious. Okay, at least minorly suspicious.
So, I would say probably Destiny if he's betting 50/50, he might
not have thought that was a minor, you know, more than 20%, 30%.
Unfortunately, that 20 or 30% is enough to go to the cops. Okay,
basically once you're informed, you kind of are bound to act
in my opinion. Okay,
but that's why you should focus on those questions cuz otherwise
Destiny will try to weasle his way through this and go, "Well,
60 gigabytes. Look, that's what they had. 60 gigabytes. I don't
know what the Why Why did you guys say I have 60 gigabytes? You
just lied. You just lied about me.
this 5 to 20 maybe,
We'll we'll see.
We'll see in the legal mindset video. Yes, guys, we'll get to
the legal mindset video. Don't worry. Don't worry. We'll get
there. We will get there. I promise we'll get there. Okay. I'm
aware of the legal mindset video and we will get to it. All right.
Ethan is literally reading off revenge leaks of mine and giggling,
coughing because he's too lazy to use his inhaler like a child
for DMs that had absolutely nothing to do with the rose leak.
Any reference to orgies or anything else was literally in the
context of DMs with a 26-year-old British person. I've never
DM'd uh I've never DM'd that rose person on IG in my life. Uh
what was that? Hold on. That was a another sub. Nope. Say celebration.
I'm going to turn down the kick alerts at the very minimum. Kick
alerts are going. No sound. Okay.
Uh I think Peterson Oh, this is where he edited this. Okay, we'll
get to the edit after this. It wasn't This didn't end up being
inflammatory enough, guys. He had to edit this down. Okay,
I only talked about orgies with a different woman. Okay, I'm
not gonna yuck other people's yums. You can talk about that with
an adult. Okay, you can go ahead and talk about that with an
adult. Whatever. Kind of [__] that that would get
leaked or something, but I don't know. Couldn't have happened
to a couldn't have happened to a nicer person. Okay,
I think Peterson was right about Ethan and Nila. You Zionist
and genocide supporter in the United States with loyalty to Israel
first. And a genocidal IDF maniac nightwriting innocent Palestinians
in the West Bank because she wasn't seeing enough bloodshed at
her desk job writing pardons for IDF
deserve all the CPS calls for the eating claims and everything
else. You deserve zero sympathy from anyone else on the internet
when you're so quick to turn around and rely on the same snark.
Snarks. Snarkers are there. Guys,
just any negative opinion of me is snark now. Any negative opinion
that's snark?
Is it a fact? Is it just a fact? Is was it a fact that she was
17? Yeah, but it's Snark. Don't look at it. It's Snark. It's
Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. Okay.
when you're so you deserve zero sympathy from anyone else on
the internet when you're so quick to turn around and rely on
the same snark that's been plaguing you for years as soon as
you think it's beneficial. I hope your prior maid takes you for
a mill in her lawsuit against you guys as well. Waving for anyone
else watching, you should assume that every single influencer
person you meet on the internet is a terrible human being with
zero values or principles. See you tomorrow for the stream.
So Ethan dropped this video last night. Uh, Destiny responded
to it, right? And Ethan had two comments. Okay. Is the claim
that the DMs are yours but with someone other than Rose? Do you
deny having your 17-year-old's nudes on your computer? And there
was one more response here from Ethan, I believe. Okay. So,
he gets this comment from when he purports to be a DJ, I believe.
Uggh. It's just so tiring when someone who's been vilified and
lied about as much as Ethan falls for some pretty obviously fake
DMs just because it aligns with a narrative that is also likely
missing so much information.
This is a weird virtue signal video. IMO this virtue signal thing
is going to be like a major uh PDF dog whistle going forward.
Destiny has set the narrative that like oh this is just people
are just virtue signaling because they're scared of snark communities
so they're just virtue signaling. You hear somebody call this
virtue signaling. That's a major PDF dog whistle. Okay. You can
immediately look at anybody who's calling that virtue signaling
who can't explain why it's virtue signaling.
Exactly what they are. Okay. Ethan realizing he's been gaslit
for 2 years.
It was just DMS. Didn't they find the girl? They did find
that the girl Destiny was having sex with was with was 17 at
the time. Okay. What does virtue signal mean? It means it's a
meaningless expression of how good you are to plate other people
and make yourself look better. Right? So he's saying you're just
trying to plate people or make yourself look better by attacking
me. It's a virtue signal. It's not a virtue signal. It's a legitimate
criticism. And he's blaming it on Stark. And again, it's facts.
It's not snarky opinions. It's not, you know, people building
totally wrong narratives about you. It's not Stark that that
did this, right? I don't know how you could call it Snark when
Destiny went to the Starkers and was like, "Here's more information
on this girl." Hi. You're You're too dumb to find her. Here's
more information on this girl. You couldn't possibly find her.
You guys suck.
Good one. Good one. Okay, so that is the Destiny tweet that leads
off some of the Ethan, well, some of the Ethan responses and
Destiny also went live today to talk about it. Okay, we're going
to get to that in just a second. We'll do the Destiny live stream
and then we will go to the legal mindset video. Okay, guys. Do
the Destiny live stream first. Okay, we got that. We got that.
Ethan responses. Where's my Destiny stream bod? Here it is. I
jumped too far forward. Hold on. >> Um cuz I believe Destiny
actually opens up with something today that we should probably
check out. Okay, this is the this is the stream opening forum.
Let's check it out. Hold on. Hold on.
>> There we go. There we go. >> Kids
or if I believe in it.
Well,
>> you believe that I'll you know why?
>> I'm sure this is great. Somebody should uh somebody
should send a clip of this to uh Z and say look he's showing
how he's a part of America while playing this song about him
sorry he's playing this song in reference to himself and his
of a minor okay that's great optics for you guys isn't it isn't
that great optics for un America
you guys are going probably your best talking point right now
is that Trump doesn't actually care about kids and you've got
a guy who's a 17-year-old and is memeing about it on Twitter
and on his stream. Wow. You're goddamn right. I'm a literal [__]
up. My words are like a zip tie with a plastic edge. It'll tie
you to my bed. Whether you're rate nine or 10 prepubescent toddler
and fancy select baby pants address the answers heterophobic.
Nah, you're just pedophobic staring at my hard drive. My collection
is growing. That's my child. You better let go of it. It belongs
to my folder. You'll never get a hold of me. Hey, it's me, Jeffrey
Epste. Everyone respects me. I'm just kidding myself. Hit it.
Kitting
>> Wait, is Destiny botting himself right now? Possibly.
Uh maybe. I have no idea. I'd assume he gets a lot of views when
he um when like his controversy is going on. When people have
controversy, you get a lot of views. I don't know if he's Oh,
never mind. He just dropped like 1500 viewers instantly.
Um probably slightly botted. >> You should be getting some
help. Committed, medicated, or just sitting in jail. Relax, guys.
I like Shay right or he's ending stream either. Stop. >> Rumor
has it Mr. girl has a few abusive habits and I'm late for work
cuz I'm stuck in human traffic.
Yeah, I know he's falling off daughters and nieces and nephew
smash them to pieces and I wear white pants and I drive once
too. Come on kid. I got some Vbucks
and tell me to off. I don't care if I get my rocks off. I'm so
damn spent. Can't even pay my rent. Pages like the consent page
is just a number. Jail's just a place right here. Yeah, I'm your
worst nightm. They call me >> Okay, you guys get it. I
love Max, but we're not going to listen to the whole song right
now. Okay. >> Um Okay, first thing is going to be boring
as All right. First thing is going to be boring, guys. It's just
Dramma. Okay, we're just doing Drema over here. People ever bought
others to make them look bad? Yes, they do. Yeah, it's I'm not
going to read into it. Okay, I'm not going to read into it. People
do. Do people bought bought channels to make them look bad? Absolutely.
Calls the whole thing memes.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. He will. He will. My music. >> First
thing is going to be boring as [__] All right.
Okay.
I don't know why.
I do know why Willie Mack decides to run and make a video like
two hours after DMing me. Now I understand. I got
I don't know why Willie Mack runs to make a video two hours after
DMing me. Um, simultaneously he realizes he's been
he realizes the impression people have of him and what the narrative
is about him, right?
And you are literally confessing to crimes in DMs with him. I'm
sorry. Like
if dude, can we just process how mind he must have thought he
had Willie? Like he must have thought Willie is totally my puppet
in every single way. He is sitting here and going, "Man, all
I did was tell Willie that I had like seesam on my computer and
send him of the same purported CSAM and he like went to the cops
and made a video about it." Can you guys believe that? Isn't
that gross?
Can you Can you imagine, dude? He actually thought he had Willie
that on puppet
That's crazy. Get it? Okay, we have to do the destiny bad because
we're it's too much heat from other people, which listen, I get
it's a lot of heat online. Okay, that's fine. I get it.
I understand it. And Ethan obviously with this whole um I noticed
all the comments on the video where people were like where people
were like um wow I noticed that the crew was like very giddy
and excited and happy this episode when it seems like they're
usually very sullen and they don't say anything because anytime
Ethan is criticizing his son all of them are in the in the sunken
place behind their behind their desks. Uh, but when it was me,
oh, they're so excited to I Destiny being perpetually confused
about why people don't like him will never not be funny to me,
right? Like he's just totally inhuman. He doesn't have human
emotion, human feelings, and he's just like, why do people people
just don't like me? These people just like were so happy to try
to to try to talk about me. And why is everybody always so happy
when I'm in trouble? Why is everybody dislike me? He he just
it does not hit at all for him that he just doesn't act like
a person. He doesn't act like a human. He's just a complete piece
of [__] And people like watching pieces of get their
comeuppants.
That's just a that's a universal human delight. Okay. Somebody
who's a total piece of [__] getting their comeuppants.
Yeah. Absolutely. Everybody's down for that. I don't know what
you're confused
Repost or retweet or retread whatever whatever stuff pops up
online. Um,
so the thing is, so you know what? Actually, this guy said it
best. Hold on. Oh, that might be true watching you back that
they like taking out Vosch. Could be true. >> BS can't
defend yourself. >> One second. I'm going to pull this
back. I'm going to go to the bathroom really quickly and get
some water cuz we're ready to go. I've got all my caffeine digested.
Okay, we're amped. We're psyched. We've got all this content.
We've got the legal mindset video coming up. Okay, guys. Give
me two seconds. I'll be right back. >> Wait. Guess can't
defend yourself. Answer here. I'm trying to meet your request
of giving non-stop defense because your baby ass can't defend
yourself. Keemstar will make insane accusations, crownless accusations.
And then he expects you to defend yourself. In fact, he likes
it if you'll come on your his show and defend himself. That's
how his operation works. And so he goes, "Oh, well, he didn't
say anything in his defense, so he must be guilty." Have you
ever lied to anyone on YouTube? What are you the [__]
FBI? I don't think >> I'm not going to play this game of
every single time some insane person releases some random
or piece of paper or whatever that I'm going to come and run
through all these communities and try to give some crazy explanation
for whatever else. Because one, the only thing that's happening
is I see that every single thing I possibly say gets either misconstrued
or drawn out to the most absurd reality possible to where Nicholas
Oreo cakes or whatever is saying that I'm threatening Willy's
wife because I said she was a massage agent, which I have I'm
back. I'm back right now. I'm back. Okay, we got to roll it actually
all the way back. I'm sorry. It's just too dense right off the
bat. I Dude, what is this? What is this clip he plays as if this
means anything?
Why is he pretending that that like the allegations against him
are like something from Keemstar? Why is he pretending that's
even close?
Non-stop defense because your baby can't defend yourself. Keemstar
will make insane accusations, crownless accusations, and then
he expects you to defend yourself. In fact, he likes it if you'll
come on your his show and defend himself. That's how his operation
works. And so he goes, "Oh, well, he didn't say anything in his
defense, so he must be guilty." Have you ever lied to anyone
on YouTube? What are you theing FBI? I don't
>> I'm not going to play this game of every single time
some insane person releases some random
or piece of paper, whatever that I'm going to some random or
piece of paper or whatever. All right, the
was
random piece of paper that doesn't really apply to anything.
There's a litany of information that proved okay via tying this
person's identity to uh tying this this person's face to an identity
and then using a government database that proved that the person
Destiny was a minor when he was them. It's not random and it
is new information. So he goes with two primary narratives here
from what I've seen. One is that all of this is just driing things
up that happened in 2022. Oh, we've dealt with all this drama
already. This is us just This is my haters dragging something
up from 2022 that doesn't make any sense. Everybody knew this.
We saw Connor test this one out. It's
It doesn't work, right? It doesn't work. Obviously, there's a
bunch of brand new information here that makes no sense to say,
right? And the other one is what what else does he say? The other
one's the snarker narrative. Oh, this is just like snark. This
is snark. You can't trust this. This is from Kiwi Farms. This
is this snark stuff. Okay. He's trying to do these two. Oh. Uh,
and then that the only reason Willie and Ethan are doing this
is because they're virtue signaling because they're scared of
the snark communities, right? Uh, he's trying to portray Ethan
as a hypocrite because Ethan is the same as Keemstar. Keemstar
repeats rumors so people come to him to defend himself. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I realize what he's trying to do. But the thing is
Keemstar has a reputation for like going with salacious rumors.
This this in itself or Ethan even does. This might be a valid
comparison. Okay. But not in this case.
Not in this case.
It's absolutely not a valid comparison in this case. Not even
close. I'm going to come and run through all these communities
and try to give some crazy explanation for whatever else because
one, the only thing that's happening is I see that every single
thing I possibly say gets either misconstrued or drawn out to
the most absurd reality possible to where Nicholas Oreo cakes
or whatever. See, this is I I don't even have that much hate
for Nick on this now that I think about it because like obviously
they're going to use something and Nick just happened to be the
person who got the most soy. Okay. Yeah, Oreo cakes isn't funny.
I know. Um, see what Destiny's trying to do there is he thinks
that when he who megal somebody that it matters. Unfortunately
for him, the who megaling thing only works when people give any
amount of a about your opinion or think you have a solid reputation.
When they think you're somebody to be respected and who they
seek the respect of. After all of this stuff has come out, I
don't think anybody's like that. So when he who megal somebody,
they probably just go like, "Oh, I'd probably feel better that
you don't know me." Actually, I would I'd like literally rather
you don't know who I am. That's that would actually be better.
I'd prefer not to. Aren't you like the doxing degenerate like
community? I don't I don't really want to be a part of that.
If you could just leave me out if you pretend you don't know
me, that'd be good.
Right. So, what he should do here is he has the reputation his
reputation roughly in line with somebody like Ethan Ralph. He
should just do what Ethan Ralph would do, right? Just totally
just totally go unhinged on Nicholas. Just start calling him
fat. Start calling him all kinds of names. Right? That's what
you should do here. That's who you are now. That's your reputation.
You have like the you have a totally torched reputation. It is
at -20. Okay. Out of 10.
You can't you can't just attack this guy. You can't go, "Oh,
I don't know who you are." Yeah, nobody cares.
Okay. But this is him not It hasn't set in yet that like nobody
respects him. He's lost everything. just hasn't said inform.
He still thinks that he can go, "Oh, who is this? I don't even
know who this is." Nope. Can't do that anymore. >> Is saying
that I'm threatening Willy's wife because I said she was a MSAD
agent, which case I have to clarify was a joke. Okay, I wasn't
joking. I'm sorry for that joke. To the best of my knowledge,
okay, I can't say 100%. To the best of my knowledge, Willy's
wife is not a massage agent. Okay, number one. And number two,
so really the only thing we're waiting for here is him to respond
to, "Did you DM a 17-year-old?
How good is the evidence? What is your characterization of the
evidence that she is that that is the 17-year-old? And
did you send artifacts of the child abuse materials or whatever
it would be here? Did you send artifacts of that to a group chat
to try to find this person? Did you propagate this information
after being told by the producer of this information according
to you that it was CSAM?
That is these are the questions that we should be asking. And
these are the questions everybody needs to ask so that Destiny
feels pressured to answer them. Yes. Did you send artifacts of
this child abuse materials to a group chat?
It feeds the content network for all of these people who just
make content out of them all by responses basically no matter
what I say. Okay. Um I was hoping that I I guess Ethan wouldn't
have a wouldn't have his his uh destiny. I know that he's like
been hungry to like kind of show some disavowel of me because
every time him and Hassan fight, Hassan like uses me as some
attack vector to go after Ethan, which is weird because I mean
at least it should be proven today. I have traded a total of
two messages with Ethan in my again the total incredul that that
he just doesn't understand that Dan is clearly closely aligned
with Ethan. Clearly talks to Ethan a lot. Clearly closely aligned
with you. Clearly talks to you a lot. that is the bridge that
connects those two communities, right? That's he just acts like
he has no idea. And he does this while simultaneously saying
with no evidence that my community is connected to Kiwi Farms,
that Chud's community is connected to Kiwi Farms, right? That
Queen's community is connected to Kiwi Farms. So he'll do those
connections, but he can't in his mind even remotely acknowledge
that people would think, oh, that Danbridge is what connects
those communities.
my entire life. I've said this before. I think it was like
I don't even know when it was after October 7th when um Hassan's
chat was like spamming insane and I went over on stream and I
think Ethan DM'd me and he asked me. He was like, "Wait, where
did you get the chat message from?" I told him. I think this
might be 2 years ago. Yeah, these are So, but I think Ethan is
like so desperate to get away from the just controls me narrative
that he decides to do his little unhingeable stream. Yeah, I'm
going back to the where I was before. Unhingeable, which is I'll
wait until my court case is over. Uh, I'll go over filings as
they come out, but >> we've got a Nick response to the
Destiny clip. Hold on. >> I'm going to play this game of
every single time some
releases some random
or piece of paper or whatever that I'm going to come and run
through all these communities and try to give some crazy explanation
for whatever else. >> Uh, let me predict.
Bro, the crazy thing here is proof that you got CSAM. You had
CESAM on your hard drive.
Like
you dude, you just had CESAM. There's no way you could possess
C, Sam. I think that's all it's going to be. Okay. >> The
only thing that's happening is I see that every single thing
I possibly say gets either misconstrued or drawn out to the most
absurd reality possible. >> I absolutely hate when this
happens. I totally agree with him. It happens all the time. Like
somebody will go and take a tweet, for example, and hop on stream
and just completely lie about the context to their entire audience
and thousands of people think that you said something that you
didn't say. Nicholas Oreo Cakes or whatever is saying that I'm
threatening Willy's wife because I said she was a MSAD agent,
which in case I have to clarify was a joke. Mr. Oreo, it was
such a good joke. Also, I literally never said that. I said that
you are targeting Willy's wife, which is exactly what you're
doing because you're mad that Willie reported you to the police
because you told him you had alleged child. I mean,
it's somewhere in the middle there, right? targeting Willy's
wife is technically correct. But the whole thing is if I said,
"Oh, Willy's wife is uh I don't want to talk about Willy's wife.
I'm technically or not quite that. Hold on. If I said Willy wife
Willy's wife is like an ugly woman,
would that be like
That's not even a joke. Dude, I'm not I'm not on the money right
now. Hold on. There's something here. There's It's just It's
a joke. Saying targeting implies like some super big harm there.
And I've watched when Destiny targets
There's not like a lie he's really fueling here. This is him
joking. Okay, hold on. We'll we'll walk in. It's not like a lie.
He's not like maliciously lying here. He's not doing creative
writing on Willy's wife. This is like a joke leaning into some
other jokes. I just don't think it's even close on your computer.
Then you jumped into your chat and you started talking about
everybody. And one of the things you included was talking about
Willie Max show's wife. And then after all that was said and
done, you responded to me and for some reason just didn't answer
when I asked you about all that alleged CSAM material on your
computer. So I figured this is like a better opportunity to ask
you about it. Maybe you'll see this one.
Yeah. Well, that's a good response from Nick. I I I tend to feel
like Nick's response was soy. Wife is completely unrelated. Uh
and Destiny mentions her because he knows she got doxed. Willie
did public content announcing that his wife got doxed. No.
You can say this. Did Willie not do public content announcing
that his wife was doxed?
And does that now put that now into the public domain? But that's
why no. Destiny mentions her because the memes that were upsetting
Willie was uh was basically the IDF thing. This is the exact
same thing as the Hassan thing, right? In the other direction.
It's like he's just he's throwing it out there because it's a
dig at the guy. It's not like targeting him in like an insane
way. It's not going insane. It's not putting somebody at risk,
right? He's not like lying maliciously about them.
I I see it as the same thing in the opposite direction. But I
don't know. Maybe maybe that's crazy. There are people already
making that dumb Assad joke. I made that joke about Nicholas.
I said, "Do we know if Nicholas has a girlfriend? Have we seen
this Israeli girlfriend for Nicholas?" Yes. No. Yes. No. It's
just a joke. It's just a joke. It's just a meme. You don't have
to get too upset upset about it, guys. Okay. It's just a joke.
That's all. That's it. That's all. Thank you for linking the
Nicholas response, though. Appreciate it. >> I I realized
that Well, I didn't know that Willie would make a video with
him crying into the >> Hold on. So, Willy's wife was doxed,
harassed, and smeared. And now that Destiny is slighted by Willie,
it's okay to slander her.
No, I don't believe that's slander. So, hold on. For it to be
slander, you would have to believe that you think Destiny believes
that or is trying to write that story. You would have to believe
that that's not sarcastic.
Do you believe that? Really, soy guy, or are you just living
up to your name?
Do you believe that Destiny is actually saying that Willy's wife
is a MSAD agent that he met and was was offered to him in Israel?
You really believe that? I'm just I'm just curious if you really
believe that. I don't know. I just I don't like soying about
jokes. Okay. Just makes you It just It just slows you down. That's
all. Just slows you down. Camera of like, "Oh, this is 911."
Record record. I can talk about more of this when my
h dude it like Willie to report Destiny, didn't it? Willie looks
so depressed making that phone call. That was like the worst
day of his life. Okay.
Easily the worst day of his life.
>> Case is over. Uh which is hopefully soon, but who knows?
>> Yeah. See, this is the this is the exact same thing
Will from Texas that people argued about Hassan and they're both
equally I'm going to call both of them out. Okay. Don't take
obvious jokes, obvious things that basically nobody could interpret
as a call to violence. Destiny literally just says this person
should be killed when he wants to do a call to violence. Okay.
He just goes, "That person should be killed. That person totally
justified to go after that person." Now, why are we acting like
this is anything close to him actually wanting violence done
to someone?
It's insane.
Just look at it objectively, okay? Don't get don't get too blinded.
Don't get too clouded. Okay? Whenever
whatever stuff gets read, um oh, now we've moved to the whatever
like 17 18. Here's the thing, okay? when it comes to ages for
hooking up.
>> No. What?
Okay. I'm trying to be chill about this reaction cuz I have a
feeling that this whole stream is just set up to get like soy
reactions out of people. He's doing Destiny's got a couple different
tactics for like um changing public narrative. One of them is
he will say things that like rage bait and he wants you to soy
out about them. Okay, I suspect that is a tactic he will employ
today. And what he just did here is he is accused of having CSAM
on his computer of spreading artifacts of that CSAM to multiple
people. And what he's going to actually talk about is age of
consent arguments. There's no way, right? There's no way that
Destiny would go through here and say,
I'm going to do I'm just going to argue about like what the Age
of Consent No, right? No,
no.
But I'm not going to soy about it too much because obviously
he's just looking to get reactions out of people. Let's see the
Ethan uh the Ethan story here. Destiny fans, here's the issue.
You say nobody knows for sure if she was 17 when the nudes were
exchanged. The fact that Destiny has even put himself in the
position to receive naked photos of a minor, even inadvertently,
is a massive problem. This man clearly exploits his vulnerable
fans for gratification. He was 33 at the time and she was 17/18.
How can anyone defend this? I don't know if Rose was a fan when
they met. I think she did end up she started watching clearly.
I don't know for sure if she was a fan or not. I'm actually not
sure, but we'll keep watching. We'll keep watching with people
in general. Like, I feel like you can play this game. Hold on,
let me let me uh pull it back. >> Here's the thing. Okay,
when it comes to ages for hooking up with people in general,
like I feel like you can play this game like regardless of how
far you want to go. 18 and older is an adult in the United States.
If people are like, "Oh, you should wait until they're 21." Then
I feel like it would just move to 21 and older. Like, oh, why
are you hanging out with a 21-year-old? Or why you hanging with
a 23-y old? Like listen, age is just a number, guys. Age is just
a number. Don't forget, age is just a number. It doesn't really
mean anything, right? If it was 21, they'd be mad at me for hooking
up with somebody who is 21 or 20. If the age of consent was 21,
people would be mad at me for hooking up with somebody who was
20.
And wouldn't that be silly? Yeah, I know that's not at all what
happened here and I'm creating a hypothetical where I might not
be quite as bad a person, but you know, imagine imagine the age
of consent was way higher than it is and then I a 20-year-old
or I tried to exchange nudes with a 20-year-old.
Guys, guys, if you're an adult, if you're an adult, I don't know
what the point is of moving the bar on this. If you think that
like 18 years old is like a horrible age of people to hook up,
then maybe we can make like tax brackets for for hookup consent.
But I don't know.
Uh,
hold on.
Just to be clear, this is you trading.
He's he's just totally uh blurring the lines here, right? The
the allegation is after you had reason to believe you had some
suspicion that she was a minor, you then shared artifacts from
the CSAM she sent you, from the potential CSAM she sent you that
you shared with other people in order to try to find her.
I think Ethan's really [__] up the criticism here,
but that's what Ethan does. We won't let that We won't let that
throw us off too much. Okay. Ethan constantly does like bad research.
He things up. He This is what he does. Okay. That's a classic
Ethan thing to do. All right.
Seam she sent. Yeah. Oh, she sham she.
You considered being an interrogator? No, I have not. But he's
just uh he's he's just slowly like trying to blur the lines on
all of this, right? Oh, they're basically like she was basically
18 and and man, like is that even where the line should be? And
it's it's not a useful exercise. And why do we have to come up
with hypotheticals? Let's just like you can do hypotheticals
all the time, but why in this situation where we have concrete
facts are we doing hypotheticals? Why not just address the situation
as it is? Why do a hypothetical about anything else? There's
just no reason, no need. We don't need a hypothetical here. You're
not driving home a different point. You're just obiscating from
the point that you don't want to deal with. >> No, like
it's just funny to see the bar moving this. I don't care. Whatever.
Listen,
I'll say what I said before. Okay. Whatever you've read about
me online or whatever you want to post about me, it's true and
worse. Okay. All of it is true and worse. We're doing the uh
the gigachad through spreading seam allegations. Okay, that's
that's what we're doing now. We're doing the gigachad through
that. Very interesting,
guys. Oh, you've everything you've heard about me is is you've
it's true and worse. Plays the Mr. Girl song. The I am a song
to start it off, right?
We're just We're just going to I don't know, man. This is the
one thing I never see work on the internet. Okay. Maybe Destiny's
the first guy that will ever pull this off. All right. Trying
to gigachad your way through and own the allegations. I've never
seen it work. I've never seen it not burn somebody horribly.
Okay.
Everybody who's attempted it has gotten totally destroyed, totally
torn apart over it. But he has decided that he's that guy. Okay.
At the lowest point in his career when everybody around him has
left, this is the point where he is now going to own the allegations
totally and and come out the winner. I don't know. Anybody got
bets?
Anybody got bets on on whether that's going to work or not? Worse.
Okay. The feds are coming.
The cases are mounting.
The
MSAD and the KGB are tracking. Okay, they will be here one day.
I've been streaming. Hold on. This is just Lou guy in chat.
It's so transparent, isn't it? Isn't it transparent? Only logs
he sent in the channel. I mean, people are already over this
to be honest. Nobody's talking about it already. Do people really
not read this as a joke? I mean, come on. I think it has worked.
It's been a day and it looks like everyone has stopped caring
already. I don't know. Okay. Okay. All right.
That's very very funny. Am I wrong? I don't think most people
have talked about it yet. I think I think a lot of people are
going to be talking about this for a while. That's must be pray
praying that a bigger YouTuber doesn't make a video. Oh, videos
are coming. Neosick videos are coming. Okay.
H.
It's crazy that people are like, "Oh, I don't I don't know if
there's going to be I don't know if people are really caring
about this or talking about it." No. No videos are coming. Oh,
this is what he means. Hold on. I'm looking at LSF and nobody
is talking about it. That's how I see this. If it was Hassan,
there would be a million posts. Yes, the the place that's totally
astrourfed in favor of Destiny. Nobody's talking about it there.
Oh, that's that's crazy. I can't believe that. I can't believe
there's nobody talking about it in the place that's totally astrourfed
in favor of Destiny. That's crazy.
Uh, that is crazy though. That is crazy. Anyway, I'm going to
leave that guy here. He can continue to do his little bit. I
just think it's I just had to look at it. Whenever I see a comment
that seems like out of line with what everybody understands,
I just click on it and I'm like, I wonder if there's just Yeah.
Oh, it's a it's a clear DGER.
Uh, and I think as we go through this, we'll see that this is
the goal of Destiny, right? He's trying to he's trying to arm
his audience to go and start saying that this is all lies everywhere,
right? Just to just totally say this is like a total lie and
then as soon as you get proof, you probably just dip out of the
conversation. Yep. Guys, isn't this like totally made up by like
snark communities and like Kiwi farms and and why would you take
this seriously? Guys, look at where the information came from.
Please just the the first thing you should know when you looking
at any information, okay, is to look at the source of the information.
Screaming for 16 years, but this is the last one. Okay, the walls
are closing in this time. For real, for real, for real. Okay,
they're closing in. I swear to God, they are. All right. I have
never been more
on edge and afraid.
Oh, yeah. faithless follower. Obviously, he's responding to last
night when we're when we're uh memeing about this, right?
I mean, listen, maybe maybe
every legal professional is wrong. Maybe maybe he's just only
doing what was legal, okay? What was legally his right? All right.
Maybe he is a white hat working with the cops. It's hard to say,
man. It's really difficult to say, isn't it? Does anyone ever
care even care anymore? I don't even see any r/ Destiny posts
about this.
the walls closing in
as I am right now. Okay. Seems like you have an actual case of
defamation from Ethan. No, maybe. Maybe not. The thing is, lawsuits
suck. They're expensive. It's annoying. Um I don't even know
it's worth it. Uh and I just don't care that much because you
know what?
We just keep on
rolling. Okay,
we should keep on rolling, guys. The lawsuits. Wait, lawsuits?
Wait, are there more than Are there more lawsuits?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. >> I don't even know
if it's worth it. Uh, wait. I thought Hold on. Actually, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I thought the whole reason he didn't
want to sue people for defamation
was because
they didn't have any money. Ethan's got lots of money.
Doesn't Ethan have lots of money? Wouldn't this be defamation,
per se? You He's accused you of a crime.
Would this not be defamation, per se?
If if none of this is true,
then it seems like a pretty obvious case for you. No. >> And
I just don't care that much because you know what?
We just keep on
rolling. Okay. >> He just doesn't care. He just doesn't
care. That's why he keeps responding. That's why he keeps talking
about it. He just doesn't care, guys. He just doesn't care. He
He was totally willing to fight to the point that he was doxing
people. He was using his community to harass everybody, right?
And now he actually just doesn't care anymore. It's actually
like, guys, can you believe I even cared before? Dude, I just
don't care, man. You guys say whatever you want. I'm not going
to worry about the noise. I'm just going to sit back, brother.
This guy comes into my chat multiple times a week to try to talk.
There's nothing he cares about more than the noise.
He cares so much about it. And I don't understand how this lie
could possibly work. His community memes on him for it, right?
Like, wasn't there about a month ago, I feel like there was a
period where RTBA posted the meme about how Destiny just obsessively
reads Jtock Discord logs for like eight hours a day and now he's
now he settled in and he's like, "You know what? Now that I confessed
to uh to creating artifacts of the CES and sending it to Willy
and making that group chat to find Rose, you know, now I got
to say, guys, I don't really care anymore. I actually don't care
now.
You know, I I just don't care.
Bro, I can't believe how quick these two are to believe anything
they read on Kiwi Farms and they've been harassing them for the
last few months. You know what? That's how it goes. Okay. >> $5.
Your honor, Ethan Klein was correct that my client distributed
CSAM, but he defamed my client by reading the wrong cringe DMs.
>> Yes. Yes, exactly, Mr. Bretler. Yes, Andy B. That is
what Destiny's arguing. That's what everyone's arguing here is,
Listen, he read some totally unrelated DMs and like that kind
of isn't that kind of checkmate, guys? Isn't that like you're
just snarking? You're just like clearly snarking. You read the
wrong DMs. Yeah, you you you totally read or you you understood
Willy's video. Yes, I do have CSAM in my possession. Yes, I have
created artifacts of it and sent it to people. But listen, you
read the wrong cringe DMs and that means I go free. Actually,
them is the rules, guys. You read the wrong set of DMs, doesn't
matter what I did, I go free now. You're unreliable. I'll call
you a liar. You just make things up. Okay, them's the rules.
Tough break kid. >> I don't know why he talked to Willie
Mack at all. Um
>> I don't remember. I think he messaged me on something,
but I mean I'd been in communication with him. I just didn't
expect him to run and make a YouTube video in 2 seconds based
off some DMs with us. Obviously the I would have approached that
conversation with a lot more care in terms of how I'm phrasing
things obviously. But you know what? Wait, can you say where
you like didn't tell the truth? Cuz it seems like you sent that
and that seems to be what set Willie off, right? You know if
any of these videos were in the Google Drive? I don't know. I
don't I have no idea. I don't I doubt it. Right. But but like
I would have been really careful. How do you be more careful
about sending that to him? I don't know how you're more careful.
That wasn't phrasing. That was just this
whatever. Listen what again. Whatever you want to believe. Believe
what you want. Okay. The feds, they're on their way, right? I'm
just trying to trying to stream before they get here. Insha ABH3.
Oh, I'm so glad he finally found his voice. I wonder how awkward
it feels when his boss is sitting there railing on his
Turkish idol and he has to sit there and hold his tongue the
entire time knowing that he's getting by Hassan's entire fan
base the entire time regardless and that being a spineless actually
isn't helping him at any part of this whatsoever.
But that's okay.
>> And Ethan has to feel bad too cuz he's sitting there
while his whole crew is awkwardly staring at him because nobody
wants to participate.
It's all good. H3 has been a >> Wait, did I miss Hold on.
Did I miss the Chud thing? Did he actually pull that
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did I miss it? Did I miss
it? Did I miss it? I didn't miss it. No, I didn't miss it. >> Knowing
that he's getting by Hassan's entire fan base the entire time
regardless and they're being a >> Sorry, I was I was making
the uh He's just saying it. Yeah. Well, lots of people have been
telling him I know people have been telling him, "Oh, why don't
you compare this to Chudlogic? Don't you know Chudlogic did this
like same thing?" and and it's it's like the exact same. Um,
one, it's not he didn't have somebody who told him that that
person was possibly underage and then he decided to keep materials
related to that person. That's like the very very very key difference
here, right? That after he was informed that that person might
be underage, even if he doesn't necessarily believe that, keeping
those materials and not informing police or or going to his legal
team or going to Discord, right? Any of these things,
that's what the problem is. he had this long period where he
doesn't actually do that. I mean, sorry, that's that's the major
issue under the law to me. Like, obviously, there's a moral issue
with only using un age non-verified like non-age required platforms,
age restricted, right? Obviously, there's a bunch of problems.
We've talked about them, but like where you can just make criticisms
of him and there's just no response is on the okay, you knew
that this person might be a minor. You kept that material, but
you didn't report it because you wanted this all to blow over.
That's like very obvious. That's very clear. That is the strongest
allegation you can make right now. And he is totally avoiding
all questions on the topic.
Actually isn't helping him at any part of this whatsoever.
But that's okay. And Ethan has to feel bad, too, cuz he's sitting
there. Should Chud have been more diligent in his initial perusal,
though? Probably,
right? Probably. Um, yeah. I'm sure Chud has like criticisms
for himself. I've never actually looked into the whole thing,
to tell you the truth. I've never I've never actually looked
into the whole thing. So maybe at some point we will.
While his whole crew is awkwardly staring at him because nobody
wants to
It's all good. H3 has been a girly pop gossipy channel for a
while now. His audience is likely majority women who watch things
like RuPaul and talk pop culture celebrity relationships. It
was inevitable. Um I actually disagree. I feel like the HD fan
base for the most part is actually one of the more chiller fan
bases on the internet. Um,
I think it's because not to
not to pull my guys, I really don't have a problem with like
the H3 fan base. The H3 fan base is actually like really really
really cool. It's just that Ethan has to like use snark lies
against me. If Ethan wasn't using snark lies against me, I'd
totally be He's just This is by the way, this is um Oh, this
is very Nick Fuentes like, right? Once you once you know the
programming and the the other creator goes against the programming
that's already put into the audience, you can sweep in and just
keep programming that audience. You can keep doing the same thing,
right? Can you believe Ethan would like after what h after CPS
after the skulls, Ethan uses snark lies against me? Well, the
audience is really cool. They understand that like snark lies
are a big problem. Snark gets people killed. Okay, snark is no
joke. It gets people and Ethan will use snark lies against me
to try to get to try to turn his audience against me. That's
gross. The audience is too smart for that though. The audience
knows about snark lies. They know that snark people. Okay. And
I love the H3 audience.
It's very transparent what's going on there, right? We all We
can all see it. I think it's incredibly obvious. Uh we'll cart
out. But I think it's because it's like probably a little bit
more women versus men. like it wouldn't surprise me if that fan
base was like 40% women. Um
but then also because they do kind of like more pop cultury stuff,
it does get a bit more grounded. Like I see a lot of comments
popping up um even in that H3 separate about how like all politics
streamers are cancer and all of those communities are cancer
and that's about like 95% correct
there. It is a special
Hold on.
What I wonder what communities they were talking about there.
I wonder which communities they could have possibly been referring
to in terms of online politics being cancer.
Certainly wasn't just Assange. That's not 95% of it, is it?
Before DG took over, the H3 community strongly rejected DGG.
I know that. And we're, trust me, we'll go through some of the
stuff. Maybe I can pull one of these threads right now. Although,
I think they're getting deleted slowly. So, it's kind of unfortunate.
All right.
See this one get deleted yet? I should be archiving these to
be honest with you. The Destiny situ the Destiny incident is
exactly why live shows are important. I watched the Vaude in
Destiny today not knowing anything about the situation prior.
After reading the comments, it became clear that the story is
full of disinfo coming directly from Snark. It's disappointing
to see Ethan engage with another creator Snark community without
any research. However, had the segment had this segment been
done live, there would have been a lot of push back and fact-checking
from the audience. The H3 audience are by no mean Destiny fans.
At least the majority aren't. So, I think it says something when
everyone in the comments is correcting the story. If there had
been a live chat, it likely would have been would have either
corrected a lot of the misinformation or at the very least not
being an echo chamber of what is likely false information. I
would really expect Ethan and the crew to know by this point
that snarkers just make up and research should never come from
a snark page. Very disappointing. Please address this on Monday.
Edit: I want to be extremely clear. I am not
not defending Destiny here. He's a scumbag. I just think we should
avoid snarking and being so cavalier with topics such as these.
It's sad to see that it's just it's so obvious how it happens,
right? Like it's watching this from the outside is just
Even Asmin Gold broke down and finally reacted to the Destiny
situation. Let's go.
I'm going to need that Asmin Gold timestamp ASAP. Watching you
back. Can I get that Asmin Gold time stamp right now, please?
Please. I'm going to need that. I need it. I need it. I need
it. I need it. Thank you. Oh my god. Copy text. Let me throw
that in my docket right now. Uh, Asmin react.
Let's go. Thank you very much. Thank you very much. Okay, let's
look at some of the comments here. Turn on some music. We'll
look at comments and then we'll get back to Destiny. But like
it's it actually is so obvious what um what Destiny lays out,
right?
Like it's so obvious what he's going for. And there are so many
DJers who just hang out in here. Now, I'm guessing they're smart
enough not to use the same accounts in both places, right? I'm
guessing this is like an H3 fan, but like the the DJers have
been in this place. They've been driving this narrative for a
long time. And the issue here is Ethan like 80% 80 90% of the
story that's not fake. That's not Stark,
right? It's not Stark. The crew were always anti- Destiny. Ethan
tried to bring Destiny in, but it didn't work. Well, sir, sounds
like that crew saved Ethan. Sounds like that crew was making
the right calls. Sounds like they had Ethan's back to get out
by Destiny DG pretending to be H3 fans. Well, a lot of the DG
people are H3 fans because H3, like Ethan, is just using DG farm
talking points against Assan. Right now, I'll never tell you
that those talking points can't be valid against Hassan. Lots
of them are. Lots of them are valid criticisms of Hassan and
the things Hassan has done. Okay, that's the difference with
us and a lot of other channels. I don't need to go and tell you
that like, oh, just cuz those points came from DGG, they're invalid
or they're like totally fake, right? Some of them are biased.
Some of them are, you know, bordering on fake. Some of them are
just totally true.
But Ethan will platform all of them. Ethan just last week was
asking, "Well, uh, guys, why why is Han accepting like uh Snapchat
nudes on a non-ver age verified platform? Why is he accepting
nudes from fans on this platform that doesn't even age verify?
Isn't that concerning? Isn't that like what he criticizes other
people for, guys? Isn't that concerning, dude? Techone reacted
and slipped up and said he had experience with this type of thing.
Let's look at this. Just in case no one knows, a few days ago,
Dan Sullivan stepped down from his podcast with Destiny because
the same community that Ethan and Willie Mack uncritically sourced
the information from has been contacting Dan's wife's employer.
Just so you all understand the community we're dealing with here.
Wow. Is that is that all?
So, Dan has no problem with Destiny texting a 17-year-old.
texting a 17-year-old. Dan has no problem with Destiny keeping
that CSAM on in his possession. Dan has no problem with Destiny
creating a group chat and sharing artifacts from that CSAM in
order to find the person after he was told that was a minor,
right? That's that seems crazy to me that Dan's main reason for
stepping down would be KF contacting his wife's workplace. Do
you know why I don't you do you know why I don't think that's
real? because unfortunately I'm aware that they contact his wife's
workplace months ago and he maintained his his stance and stayed
on anything else for months. Okay, now that's not good. We totally
disavow that. Why? You don't have to bring Dan's wife or his
family into it. Okay, now you can comment on him when he's used
them for defense. Okay, you can comment on stuff like that, but
to actually do anything to go after them is insane. It's deranged.
You shouldn't do it. It's disgusting. Okay.
His wife is not aware of anything going on on the internet. That's
that's just gross. Okay. Obviously,
like just leave. If you think anything if you if you even think
that that's okay. Okay. You can go. If you're if you're even
like neutral on that, off and watch somebody else. Okay.
all that is to say, okay, this happened to Dan months ago. Dan
didn't leave anything else. So, I don't think that this is actually
the primary reason Dan is leaving anything else. Okay,
that's just my opinion. Is Creman really behind anything? He
doesn't really seem like such a boogeyman. Lol. Yeah, this is
news to me. I understand Kiwi Farm is being crazy, but Quumman
has like no viewership. What damage has he been able to do? Queen
is constantly in multiple Discords creating narratives that get
Quean is the anti- Destiny Discord queen. Okay, Queman is in
all of these different discords just telling people, okay, you
you ask Queman for his opinion on like uh geopolitics and he's
like, "Have you heard about this Destiny guy?" That's what Queman's
like. Okay, he's kind of obsessed. I've heard he's kind of obsessed.
That's is rough. Okay, there's a rough one out there.
I've seen claims of this, but never any proof. Uh that's kind
of the point. The only way to have proof is to be in these servers.
And I'm not going to subject myself to
Well, the only way to have proof would be to be like around him.
And uh I don't I don't want proof badly enough. I'm just going
to spread this with no information. No, no proof whatsoever,
guys. Okay. I'm just going to lie about this. I'm just going
to lie about this. All right. That's That's how it is. If you
read through the Desty court documents, plaintiff touches on
it, but wants it to be completely anonymous, even to the court,
which is enough for me. Wait, what? Plaintiff touches on it.
Touches on what?
This is just
Is this just an open lie? This just creative writing that Pixie
apparently said that Queen does this.
Why would you just lie about this?
Uh, weird.
Can also get go look at Destiny's Kiwi Farms ultra threads and
see all of this before it hits at the timelines.
Okay.
And
yeah, you can see you can see the fact unfortunately for us,
listen,
I'm sure if Destiny was trying to spread images of Rose and direct
me to like go look for her, I'm sure I would have been aware
of that. I I was like only vaguely aware of that even happening.
Unfortunately for everyone, okay, Destiny decided to point his
Kiwi Farms thread at this minor or sorry, at this person who
was a minor when he them to try to find them and he's admitted
as much. How in the world can you virtue signal? And this is
actually virtue signaling, okay?
Because this person is stating some preference, some principle
that interacting with kiwi farms in any way is disgusting. It's
gross. And and any information from there is is just wrong. Okay,
that's the princ that's the principle they're stating. But they
totally they totally forgive and understand Destiny putting out
PII about this rose girl so that Kiwi Farms could find her. They
they don't they don't totally like discount Destiny for that,
right? But they're willing to on innuendo alone discount Queen
or me or whoever else Destiny tries to web to them. It's just
obviously it's obviously a virtue signal, right? They do not
have this virtue. They do not care about it, but they will say
that they do. Okay,
so person, this isn't the same person responding. I was curious
about whether these claims have been legit or not, but Hutch
messaged Queen directly and just asked him to tell his audience
to leave him alone. And Quimman said he wouldn't do that and
that it was disgusting for him to ask to do that. That's not
true. What Queman said was, "I'm not going to go on there and
say you're not a Destiny Orbiter because I think you are a Destiny
Orbiter and I'm not going to lie for you." That was what he said.
Hutch saw heat coming from Kiwi Farms, right? Because uh people
because one, Desi was trying to trying to drive a wedge between
Live and Learn and Hutch. Okay.
And Queen had negatively reacted to some of Hutch's stuff. So
that had both gotten posted and they went, "Oh, this Hutch guy
is a piece of and Hutch heard about this. I I believe from Destiny.
I believe there's some indication it was from Destiny." And he
asked Queen to say, "Oh, can you say I'm not a DG orbiter?" And
Queen said, "I believe you are DG orbiter." So he won't say that.
But it's not like Quimman went easily gone and leaked those logs,
right? He could have totally gone and can you believe this guy's
such a loser that he asked me to like lie for him? He didn't
do that. I believe also, I'm going to leak this, okay? I believe
that Queman had another Hutch video in the pipeline that he paid
his editor to make, that he paid his editor to edit for him and
make a thumbnail that he decided not to publish because he didn't
want to put more heat onto Hutch. But instead of that being the
message that goes out, what actually goes out is, well, Hutch
just asked him to leave him alone, and Quum said no. Tell his
audience to leave him alone. Nope, that's not what happened.
Hutch said, "Can you make this statement that you don't believe
in, please?" Queen didn't leak the logs. Queen didn't publish
his next Hutch video, which was going to be critical of Hutch
again, I'm guessing. So, he totally backed off. And the reason
he doesn't come out and lie is that's not how you can operate
with regards to KF. KF just archives stuff and they're unhinged
towards people that they that they disagree with, right? The
way to deal with that is to just operate normally. It's like
a freak weather storm, okay? operate normally and don't be a
total piece of and you just hope that weather storm passes you
by. Okay, that's how you handle getting the eyeire of Kiwi Farms.
You don't say you don't try to change your opinions. You don't
try to shape your opinions based on what Kiwi Farms is saying
because as soon as they realize that they might shape the things
you're saying at all, they will continue to focus in on you.
Giving them an indication that they're affecting you, it's like
um it's like some horror creature, okay, that like as long as
you ignore it, it can't hurt you. But as soon as you start acknowledging
it, as soon as you jump in the night when it scares you coming
around a corner, it has control. Okay?
So you don't, it's just it is just a freak weather storm that's
going over. You don't pay attention to it, right? And any other
reaction makes no sense. That's how you deal with it. But as
soon as you give them any indication that they're controlling
you, that they can do something to you, you will be, okay? They
will keep trying to play you. They will keep trying to with you.
So that's that's how it should be. That's how it should be for
Hutch. I don't know why he uh Yeah, I don't know why why this
is getting spread. This is just an open lie. Okay, Queen did
call him disgusting for saying you you want me to like lie for
you to my audience? No. [__] you.
And that it was disgusting for Hutch to suggest that.
Anyway, he's not. Destiny hates him because Queenman hates Destiny.
That's true. Dan Sultman doesn't seem like the kind of guy to
back out of anything due to harassment. They're going after Dan's
children, too. They're doxing everyone around Destiny because
they won't abandon him.
Uh, I don't know the valid the the truth of this. Um,
yeah, I don't know. They're seriously rabid on that KF thread
today. Even at call Ethan calling him a good little case slur.
It's so disgusting.
Um, okay, that's fine. You can be really upset about the Kiwi
Farms thread. You don't have to read it. You don't have to take
it seriously.
Uh, you should just trust people who have validated some of the
information, right?
Like Willie Willie knew that information was real, right? It
was Kyla. Kyla got in Hutch's ear. I I believe it was Destiny.
I believe there's a lot of indication it was Destiny actually
from things Destiny has said.
I I believe it was Destiny directly. I'm not joking. Uh I'm genuinely
curious here. Didn't Willy M directly DM Destiny about the stuff
and got information from him direct directly from him? Obviously
though, people shouldn't be going after Dan or his wife at all
related at all related to this? Sure. Hold on. Let's just keep
I'm going to look through a couple more of these comments and
we'll get back to the Dusty thread. If anything, by pre-recording,
there should be much more time to research, prepare, do retakes,
add disclaimers, etc. to make sure it's a well solid, well sourced
video. Hold on, Richie. >> PDF piece of shoe destiny. He
deserves everything he get from here on out. Hope he goes to
Jim Hop. >> Uh, he deserves the justice that the legal
system meets out to people who have done the things he's done.
Yes, I agree, Richie. Okay. Nothing beyond that. We don't support
anything like uh vigilante justice. We don't support anything
like that. Okay. But yes, if he goes to prison, that would be
wonderful. That would be totally deserved in my opinion. That
would be wonderful. I'd love to see that. Do I believe that'll
happen? I don't know. Um it's it's tough to say. There's a lot
of a lot of moving parts there that I'm unaware of. So, you know,
but I would love it. I would love it if that happened. If he
went to prison, actually felt, you know, the the large hand of
justice on the back of his neck. Okay. We would love to hear
that. See that? See that? Not literally.
Not literally.
Jesus. I I got to control it. Okay. Okay, I got to control. There's
a demon. There's a demon in me. I got to control it. Okay, I
It's [__] up. Ah, no. Why did I click that? Hold
on. Go back to the thread. I'll read one more. I'll read one
more. We'll see what it is. The video being a standalone and
not within a live video means the excuse of, "Oh, well, it's
a live show. We make mistakes. Doesn't work for Vod on on demand
video." Well, there's still It's not like they have all the time
in the world. They're not going to pay everybody to sit there
the whole time. God bless. God bless. Nerd Knight. Thanks for
being here, buddy.
All right, what else are we doing? Oh, we're still going. We're
still going. If two researchers Okay, it's just a bunch of people
pulling up a Snark page is not good. Did they pull up a Snark
page? Using Kiwi Farms as a source when Kiwi Farms is where the
Giardia and CPS call originated from is wild.
Wait, is that where is that where that stuff was sourced from?
I thought that was sourced from H3 Stark.
Stark Stark Stark. I thought it was all Stark pages. Was it Kiwi
Farms? We just Do you notice how everybody's responsible for
everything? Everybody I don't like, everybody who hates me, everybody
who dislikes me. Uh, they're all responsible for every bad thing
said about me. I just connect them all together. They're all
a big They're all a big blob. Big amorphous blob. Yes, Ethan
and crew get things wrong so often and the live chat has has
to come in and correct it, which is fine. No one knows everything,
but if they're going to publish content without the input of
a live chat when they, oh, sorry. Then they need to be far more
diligent in their research on the topics. There have been so
many times where I'm listening and I know they're wrong about
something and I'm just hoping the chat is correcting them, and
usually they do. Without this, they're going to spread so much
misinfo. Not to mention, I'm not even watching the vids because
they're separate from the show and I don't feel like listening
to that stuff unless it's the main in the main show.
Okay.
All right. So, just it's like a lot of the same narrative just
getting propagated forward, right? Oh, man. It's it seems like
it's just all Stark and why is Ethan reading from a Stark page
and Destiny's just totally leaning into that? What? It's so weird
that they'd lie. They just lie about me in the Stark page. This
is the Stark page they got this from.
Anyway, we're back. We're back to the Destiny Bod. Um, even in
that H3 separate about how like all politics streamers are cancer
and all of those communities are cancer and that's about like
95% correct.
It is a special type of cancer. Um although again I like I would
blame I would point my fingers to Hassan and for that um and
AB and all the little um people that are hiding behind the desks
that are too afraid to say anything in those segments. I would
say that those people are like you can point fingers directly
at those types of people. >> Oh wait, this is actually
what's going to happen, isn't it? MD7401's
kind of got it here. I think this is actually what's going to
happen here. I believe Okay. I believe Ethan is now going to
go absolutely insano mode on this, isn't he?
I think I think Ethan's actually going to do research like the
whole weekend. Ethan will be doing research on this to go like
sicko mode on this guy.
Dude, I think I think this might have been this might have been
a mistake. Okay,
cuz they're going to go and they're going to go like, "Uh, yeah.
Okay, you're saying we lied? Okay, let's go find out the truth.
And they're just going to do they're going to do like a Ryan
Beardesque.
Okay, I think that's what's going to happen. We'll see. >> Blame.
Um I think it would be way more interesting and more fascinating
to have policy oriented debates. Um if somebody disagrees on
Israel Palestine, you know, we can fight over the massacres,
you know, in other places pre48, you know, justify or pre-40
justify all the back and forth fighting and who was right or
wrong. Like I think those would be super interesting and fascinating
discussions to have, but nobody wants to have those conversations.
They just want to call everybody up or whatever the [__]
else. Hold on. Wait. I just had another random fan snap me. Uh,
nude. Check this out. I'm showing it to all my friends right
now. How old is she? Oh, I have no idea. But oh, check this one
out, too. And this one out too. And this one out too. Um, but
yeah, I think um, listen, as long if that's what people want
online politics to be, then
that's what I guess that's what online politics could be. It
is what it is. Tell everyone you make more than them. I'm pretty
sure Ethan makes more than me. Those guys are loaded. AB, Olivia,
and Dan are cocktasan agents that never defend Ethan. When they
beef, it's insane.
Yeah, but I mean like it's also
Dude. Okay. Sorry, I had to walk away for a second. Uh,
dude, he is
Is there no shame with the what aboutism with the son? Is there
absolutely no shame? There's no shame at all.
It's I need somebody to take the blame it on Hassan video. Okay.
And and what about Hassan?
I need a What About Hassan song. Okay.
We need to remix it. We need the lyrics updated. Okay. What about
Hassan?
Every single time something bad is happening with this guy, it's
all about Hassan. Don't you guys understand that, Hassan? Well,
how did Hassan know that those Snapchats were from people of
age? It's so bizarre to me. Okay, that this guy's just employing.
He watched how badly this went for Keeles. He watched how badly
this went for Briana Woo during Gamergate during well basically
Bron Woo's whole career. Okay, you can't just blame it on somebody
else. Not every aspect of your conduct can be blamed on somebody
else. Okay, you will eventually have to take responsibility for
the things you've done. You can't just over and over and over
again. Well, it's all Gamergate people. It's all the Kiwi Farms
people. It's Hassan. It's
Bro, take responsibility for anything.
>> I'm pretty sure Ethan makes more than me. Those guys
are loaded. AB, Olivia, and Dan are on agents that never defend
Ethan. When they beef, it's insane.
Yeah, but I mean, like, it's also by design, too. Assan agents.
They're just agents of Assan. They don't even
>> They don't even know what they're doing.
>> It actually still works with the lyrics now, doesn't
it? >> I'm coming to kill you.
Russia and Ukraine. >> Okay, we're pausing it there. We're
going to continue, guys. Let's go.
>> Nice intro or sorry, nice little break there. Nice little
break. We keep going. >> I don't want to give them charity.
It's by design, too, because anytime these people step out and
criticize us on that entire network of people is also going to
come out and harass all of those people as well, right? So, AB,
Olivia, and all those people, if they don't tow the lefty line,
you know, they're going to come under huge fire from that side
as well. So they kind of have to because if you don't tow the
line on their side
>> uh guys can you believe that these people who are mad
that I confess to having seam and spreading cam like artifacts
of that cam to multiple people can you believe they're like concerned
about that? Isn't that like a lefty take that like spreading
seam is bad? Taking pictures of cesam and spreading it to people
to try to find the minor. That's such a lefty take, guys. That's
such a lefty take. God, it's so gross. They just they know they
have to bend to the the lefties on this and just like police
me in my DMs with minors. This is so gross. Then they're going
to get called token figures or um you know, Uncle Tom's or whatever
else. So I mean like they're I mean to be fair, they're in a
rough they're in a rough position as well. So but I mean like
it's it's whatever. That's okay.
Take a deep breath. Fortress Fortress Arc away. Not really. Oh,
I feel like I need to play a do like a one month video game break.
Fortress Arcade away, eh?
you know times are getting desperate when you have to admit that
this guy was right about everything. Okay, the hardest part is
maybe admitting Vosch was right. Lil W just need to fortress
arc. Uh-huh. Why didn't you fortress arc before this?
You know when you know when the right time to fortress arc would
have been? May 28th before you apparently decide decided to go
and taunt your KF thread with pictures of the minor you probably
that that would have been the ideal time to fortress up. Okay.
Before you did that, I'm just saying. Okay. And Destiny of course
has to be bitter admitting this because Bosch, as we discussed
last night with Queen, Vos had this guy. I I've been saying this
for months now. Spitebased politics. Yeah, that's all it is.
That's clearly all it is. The whole time, right? the whole time.
It's just Vosch had him Vosch had him pegged from the beginning.
Unfortunate. It's too bad that Vos is uh kind of out of his mind.
All right. That just he Vos just sees the world a certain way
and he doesn't even look at the facts of what he's watching.
He just says based on my worldview, this is what happened here.
Sometimes that worldview is a little correct.
The state penitentiary is a great place to start a fortress arc.
Dude, could you imagine? Somebody just said uh you should stream
playing Prison Architect. Let's go. >> I still think the
I still think the Ryan Beard memes were probably my favorite.
The making the video of me who has the scariest and most dangerous
community on the internet and then announcing that he's making
a video on Hassan Ethan and that he's going to be fair and the
lefties bully him so hard he has to stop. He can't even he can't
even finish his research for the video. I think that was funny.
How is it that after uh what happened with Ryan Beard? I think
Ryan Beard thought both sides of that were pretty bad. But guess
what? the H3 side. The unaged part on Twitter for the H3 side.
That's like 80% DGG.
It is. It's like 80% DGG, dude.
That's not It's not like you your community had no participation
in that. I don't know why we'd pretend that,
And don't worry,
don't worry. I'm sure I'm sure Ryan will find his spine on the
Hassan and Ethan stuff. I'm sure he will. I appreciate that guy.
Every drama/c scandal involving you is over and settle down.
you seem to somehow get right back into it cuz I cuz like 95%
of it is
um and I don't know 95% of this is guys what what 95% of it
hold on what 5% is real just actually hold on no no no actually
just give me the 5% that's real okay can we can we get the 5%
of this that's real I just love cuz he will never make definitive
statements on the record right that's why it's like well I think
it was like this I maybe it was like That's why he never goes
and checks before he says these things. It's why he always does
conditionals every single time because he knows that he doesn't
want to be held to his statements.
>> It just it is what it is. And I have a penchant for
dealing with
crazies online, I guess. Although this might be the one. There's
somebody openly pursuing criminal justice. There's somebody um
there's somebody who's pursuing a civil case against you. There's
another offer or demand letter from somebody else wanting to
pursue a civil case against you. There's multiple other people
who could possibly pursue civil cases against you. I don't know
where where does this become fake. I need to
I I want to know like where does this hallucination come from?
What could he possibly refer to as fake? This is this is it.
Have you sworn off friendships with content creators? Yeah, kind
of. I like I'll say this again and I don't think I this message
can't carry. The thing that's the most annoying I think about
all of this is that she was actually 12. No, I'm just kidding.
The thing that's the most annoying about all of this is that
um flood the zone jokes. >> I think a lot of people and
I keep seeing these comments pop up on my own subreddit. I might
have permaned you for this also. By the way, if I perman you
just email the mods and I'll they'll unban you. Okay. The most
annoying thing is like people keep thinking that all of this
drama keeps popping up like every month, every 6 months like
over and over and over again. Oh, this is the worst talking point.
Right. This drama if you want to call it drama. Okay. You kind
of insane to call it drama, right? Not really drama. It's you
minor um and spreading artifacts of that cam in a group chat.
All right.
Which you've actually confirmed to us for some reason. Okay.
But he's going to make this argument that guys, they're just
dragging this stuff up from 2022 or it's the same thing every
3 months. It's this JTO community bringing this stuff up over
and over and over again. It's not right. He's the person who
three months ago, less than three months ago, decided to at his
ops in his Kiwi Farms thread and say, "Hey, you guys suck at
this. You're like all just losers home on disability. Here's
even more pictures. Here's private pictures I had of Rose that
have never been published, okay? And here, try to find her. Then
go for it, cuz you're just losers who couldn't possibly find
her."
like the gall to come and say that this was brought up out of
nowhere when he is the person who set this this new drop into
motion. He is but for his actions, it's never revealed. It is
I don't know how it ever gets revealed other than I assume that
when this all happened, you know, the the the fact about um Solo
saying that Rose was a minor, I'm positive that that would would
have been investigated by somebody, right? Like I think people
in the KF thread were talking about calling the FBI. Uh he said
he got called by the FBI and blamed it on me. Like I I I felt
like probably you're going to get something through there, but
now we know for a fact Willie says he he did this.
>> like I I think um your pay >> I don't think justice
would have ever been avoided here. Hold on a second. memes that
all the cases are totally stacking up guys. But at the same time,
he can't comment on the Kum crime due to his other case of distributing
totally
Yeah, he says this a lot, right? Hey, this is really inconvenient
for me. I actually have legal cases. I can't talk about it. And
then he'll constantly talk about it. He'll constantly refer to
it, right? Even in ways that hurt him. Like it's totally insane
to say, I yeah, I sent this to a group chat already. Yeah, we
tried to find this person.
It's totally wild for him to do that.
But apparently now when he when he starts getting acted or asked
pointed questions now he'll go, "Oh, guys, I I can't comment
on this." You know, I've got I've got a court case. I've got
a court case, guys. I've got court cases. I can't I can't talk
about this. Totally fake excuse. >> It's not It's the same
story that gets rehashed or refiltered. >> Oh, here. I'll
I'll let us all I'll let us listen. >> You just email the
mods and I'll they'll unban you. Okay. The most annoying thing
is like people keep thinking that all of this drama keeps popping
up like every month, every 6 months, like over and over and over
again. And it's but it's not. It's the same story that gets rehashed
or refiltered in a slightly different way from the revenge leaks
at the end of 2024. Like it's the same story over and over again
with a new twist or a new thing or a new ad. It's really really
not just the the same story. It's really not. It's really not.
I The other funny thing that happens here, okay, is
yes, hold on. Kilo's got it. Kilo's got one of the things here.
Destiny, in a private server created exclusively to find Rose,
sending a video of her to 10 other people, captioning the post.
Did you guys see the money on this one? Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Kilo, that's not new, is it? That's not a That's not a That's
not a new thing. Please tell me that's It feels like a joke.
I'm 90% sure it's a joke. 99% sure it's a joke. I just need to
make sure cuz part of that the start of that is true.
There's no way that that's real. That Okay. No. No. Kilo's
Listen, it was a joke, but I'm like, dude, I'm sorry. Lots of
the times where where people tell me what's happening.
Okay.
I feel like it's not real.
There's no way. Although, I will say I do expect at some point
leaks from that [__] to come.
hold on. I need to back it up again real quick. at the end of
2024. >> Oh, right, right, right. He says it's all the
same thing getting rehashed. He's the person who said if they
ask about how old this girl was, that's just Kiwi Farm's lies.
That's just Kiwi Farm's narratives that this girl could have
been a minor. Guys, that don't don't take that seriously ever.
There's no proof she was a minor. And now, now it's been proven
that she's a minor. Guys, why are you talking about this again?
Why are you like, why are you bringing this up again?
Why are you bringing it up again? This thing he explicitly said
was a lie has now been proven correct, right? that he was using
to discredit people who brought it up. And he goes, "Guys, why
are you lying about this? Why or why are you bringing this up
again? We already talked about this. We already knew this. We
already knew she might have been a minor. Why are you acting
like this is new information?"
Uh-huh. Poor. Like, it's the same story over and over again with
a new twist or a new thing or a new added, whatever. But people
have this perception that there's like a crazy thing happening
like every few months, but it's not a crazy thing happening every
few months. It's just a stupid for this person I talked to back
in 2022, 2023, 2020. Yeah. It's just annoying. >> That's
just a total lie. >> Can you respond to Willy's reply?
Because to be honest, your defense is not convincing. Good. I
hope it's not, but the reality is is literally
uh I know Willie did some new posts. I don't know if Desty's
kept posting. Um I don't think I went and grabbed any of the
Willie posts actually, but there there are more Willie posts
as well. Every single thing I've said has gotten twisted and
has gotten morphed or moved to like the most ridiculous in the
universe. So, I'm going to shut the [__] up and not
talk about this till my court case is over. Okay? Because I'm
this court case that is unrelated.
I'm binded bound bounded binded.
I'm I'm restricted like 15 different ways from saying stupid
such that in talking about um Bro, you need at least a hundred
different bindings to keep you from if you're already if you
feel like you're bound from saying stupid. Okay, you are not.
You have said some of the dumbest things we've ever witnessed
a content creator say on the internet. Okay, that whatever is
binding you currently, it's not enough. Tell Andrew Brettler
he needs more. Okay, you need to be tied down. You need me in
a straight jacket to keep you from on from getting on your phone,
getting on your computer. You should not be typing. You should
not have access to a computer. Like, holy [__] guys.
It's there's so many things preventing me from speaking. And
when I say that, I mean there's so many things preventing me
from clearing up the insane things I've already admitted to.
A hearing that I had with uh Pixie, like their lawyers already
like I think two days ago like moved to file a motion like we
were trying to get this thing sealed and he's still talking about
the transcript. So like no, it's not. That's a totally valid
motion that essentially no lawyer contends with. No, no, sorry.
Uh has contentions with. You have a judge ordered that transcript
to be sealed until they could review whether or not it needed
to be sealed permanently or for the rest of the case. You in
violation of that judge's order read from the transcript verbatim
on a live stream. That is a clear that is a clear undermining
of that judge's authority. That is a clear flooding of the court's
authority. Okay? You did that intentionally.
And every single lawyer that I've seen comment on it says, "That's
an insane thing to do. Why would you ever do that?" He's literally
Dude,
uh, I actually have to go pull up the Felix clip. This is where
This is where the Felix clip comes in. Okay, you guys saw the
Felix clip I tweeted earlier today. That's where it comes from.
Okay, was me thinking of this exact thing. You guys are naming
people that are like offenders and and out there racist and
people that promote harm and [__] Yo, that's not
cancelled. That's the law.
That's the [__]
>> When you do a crime, you go to jail.
>> You're not cancelled. You're a criminal.
>> It just feels so good. Hold on. Notice his face after
he finishes. That's the That's the best part. Okay. >> God
praising though.
It's his eyes wider. All right.
think Daryus is going to join the fold or was he just memeing?
I have no idea. No idea. I doubt he turns on Destiny to be honest
with you. But
that's like, dude, he just keeps committing crimes. He keeps
like not even committing crimes. He keeps violating the the like
court orders and that he's like, I can't believe they filed a
motion about my my violation of a court order. Why would they
file a motion to say that I should be held in contempt for violating
a co a court order? Like because that's what every lawyer does
when the opposing side violates a court order meant to protect
their client.
That's that's obviously what would happen in that exact situation
every single time.
Yeah. That's literally what every lawyer would do. I
Dude, he's been operating without consequences for so long that
he is just baffled when they hit him.
Usually when I like when I just call somebody an insane, that
means everybody stops. I called this woman an insane I call Pixie
an insane like four times.
Don't you understand? I can do anything to her now. Mr. Judge,
Mr. Judge, don't you understand? I could call Pixie anything
I want. I can say anything I want about her. She's an insane.
Oh, that doesn't work here. What? Worth it cuz none of it is
obviously doing me any favors anyway. So, uh, yeah, this is not
an argument that I'm going to win at the moment publicly, which
is fine, but
just have to wait until wait until my case is >> I thought
it was cases. Aren't there
I'm I'm telling you that this guy
he's gonna keep torching his online reputation until he actually
breaks his community apart. And as soon as his community isn't
there as like a cudgel hanging over like Molina's head and a
couple other people's head, oh boy.
Right. Cuz I'm telling you guys, I think Molina has the best
case on the the um out of the people who were in the initial
leaks, okay? the November leaks and she hasn't done some she
hasn't done anything and if I think if she's not scared of DG
coming after her oh it could get bad for him he could have to
hire Andy B for a whole other case that could be rough okay I
just saw our favorite guy our favorite chatter okay Destiny how
do you feel about Nicholas Dioro using Dan leaving his evidence
you are wrong when he's getting his family doxed I'm again I
hate to like talk about it too much but um Dan was in a similar
situation a couple months ago and he didn't leave Okay. So, I
think there's probably something else that's changed. There's
probably some other piece of information that's come to light
that changes things more substantially.
Uh, as as terrible as that is, we don't. We hate that. Okay?
We've already talked about how if you think that that's even
okay. Not even like I'm saying I'm not even saying if you uh
if you think it's good, leave. I'm saying if you think it's okay
or it's like neutral, you should go. You should go to a different
community. You shouldn't be here. Okay? Going after his family
is insane. It's stupid. Makes you look like monsters. Okay.
Anyway, recently heard you say you used to play Eve Online. Any
chance we get some casual Eve gameplay or are you done with it
for good? Uh, Eve gameplay. Well, actually, I shouldn't say anything
cuz I haven't played the game in
maybe a decade.
Is sitting on a gate or on a P >> for 6 hours praying to
God that the enemy fleet warps in so you guys can actually do
something and praying to God you don't get wiped by stealth bombers
or something first. or there's a really cringy sino drop that
nukes your whole fleet because you weren't ready for ships to
come in or whatever. But I'm genuinely asking this is
how is it that you don't break down when it seems you have friends
moving around every few weeks? I've been watching you for 3 years.
I'm a new viewer and it seems you have friend changes every few
weeks and everyone turns to you every so often. Except Dan. I
understand the online world is a wild place but I believe that
that the what the average except Dan. Except Dan. Except Dan.
I'm sorry if Dan's not leaving for this.
I don't know, man. Sorry. Hold on. These are um I just got sent
this meme. Okay. Critical meme update from the from the J-ST
meme desk. Okay. Critical meme update. This is every time Destiny
tries to ask Rose to come see him or that he says he'll come
see her. All right. This is every time. This would be April 9th.
Oh, the same day. Crazy. Well, hey, whenever you've got time
and want to come out to Miami, smiley face. Fun times. I grew
up Catholic. Smiley face. Also, question. And seriously, no pressure.
It's whatever works/ is it comfortable for you. Let me know.
At the end of this month, I've got a bunch of travel stuff coming
up. I could swing by blank for a day or two. If you're down,
just let me know.
Uh,
hold on. Which one's first? This one's first. Yeah, I saw. But
90 pages me. Lol. And hey, if you ever want to come to Miami,
just let me know. I can always pick up the ticket. Would I be
able to stay at your place? Sorry if that's weird to ask. Yeah,
I think it's mostly Yeah, of course you can. Duh. I'll even pick
you up from the airport. Mad smiley face.
Yeah, maybe so. And if you're ever down to fly down, I could
always fly you around places. I'm going to sliting. I have no
idea if that's scary for or anything for you though.
All right, hold on. Hold on. My next layover is in blank. If
my flight tonight gets canceled, I'm going to come abduct you
somehow. KK smiley face. I might. We'll see. And Oh, yeah. Hey,
if you ever want to fly down for a night or two, I've got lots
of airline points. XD.
Hey, or if you ever want a free trip to Miami for a couple nights
in the next couple weeks, just let me know. XD. Yes, it would
be so hot. For my next college event, I need to go. I need to
go to blank. Okay. Damn. Could be a lot of fun. I haven't had
sex in weeks now. Oh no. If only you were free to fly to Miami
for a day or two.
This guy is
Guy is persistent. He loves his legal anime type college girls.
Okay. Was Was Rose a legal scholar by chance? He's pursuing this
like she might be some kind of legal scholar because we all know
that's the thing he goes for, right? Legal scholarship, like
lawyer type girls. Was she a 17-year-old law student perhaps?
I love She was an illegal scholar. Okay.
Scholar of what? Hard to say, but illegal almost certainly. Okay.
Okay. All right. Got to get back to this. Average person thinks
he's important. Obvious how you maneuver in life. That makes
sense. My baseline, I've said this a lot. I don't think people
believe me when I say this. Generally, if somebody has a hard
time understanding me or if somebody thinks there's something
that is just doesn't make sense, it's usually cuz people don't
take what I say at face value, which is fine. I don't care. Um,
that's because I'm somebody misunderstands me, it's because they
don't take what I say it's face value.
Um, wait, hold on. Isn't there like a would there be like a reason
for that?
cuz like usually when people don't take your word at face value,
it's because they found some reason not to take your word at
face value, right?
Like yes, if I if I'm misled by your words and your actions are
not in line with your words, then I'm not going to take the things
you say at face value. Like when you said Anna was totally schizophrenic
and chasing you around and there was no reason for her to do
that, right? And she was saying, "Stephen, we have the nicest
DMs." You're basically like, "No, you're a crazy stalker." And
then we find out that you guys were DMing,
right? There might be a reason not to take your words at face
value. I Dude, it's like, dude, people who won't let me manipulate
them are like the worst. Those are like the worst human beings.
They just won't let me manipulate them. That's so up, guys. Apparently,
if somebody has a hard time understanding me or if somebody thinks
there's something that is just doesn't make sense, usually cuz
people don't take what I say at face value, which is fine. By
the way, I just want to point out the best example of this is
me letting Kelly do that chemistry thing and me just sitting
there and saying it's going to be so funny when Destiny reacts
to this in full because he's a totally insecure loser who can't
help but react to a woman telling him he's wrong about something.
It's going to be hilarious when he watches this whole thing,
right? And he hears me say that multiple times throughout the
segment and can't hit pause or stop or move on to anything his
audience is interested in. like, "No, actually taking your world,
your world, your word at face value would never let me make that
comment or let me do that analysis that totally predicts your
actions." He'd say, "No, Kelly. Kellyy's crazy. I don't care
about what Kelly says. Who cares about what Kelly says?" That's
what he would say, right? But then he gets criticized and he's
got to watch the entire [__] thing.
How many of your streams are going to be evidence at the trial?
I have no idea. I have no idea. No idea. >> Fine. I don't
care. By the way, still don't know if any of that chemistry on
either side was really correct.
Right. The whole thing I knew was that it would make this guy
see that was funny to me.
That was it. Still don't know. Still don't care about the chemistry.
>> That's because I'm a secret secret manipulator
slash mentalist slash whatever else. Um my expectation for people
online is already as low as it possibly can be. Like I kind of
every online friendship there's just like a fuse attached to
it. I just don't know what the timer is on the fuse. That's just
how I approach. >> Is that like for everybody? Can everybody
fail? Does everybody fail to maintain online friendships or there
are a lot of content creators? I seem to like recall Hassan has
maintained friendships with people for like a very long time.
What What does Hassan have that Destiny doesn't aside from a
soul?
Seems like a lot of people can maintain these online friendships.
A lot of the a lot of people don't necessarily have like these
kinds of problems. Like I Yeah, I really don't get it. It seems
to be like a uniquely Destiny problem that he can't maintain
friendships with people, that he can't maintain connections to
people, that anybody he gets close to eventually leaves and and
has a story about how he's a total piece of [__]
right? Isn't that that seems to be the case.
Speaking of totally unrelated, Lauren Southern and uh his ex
unfollowed him today. Unlucky. Unlucky, guys. Totally unrelated,
though. Hey yo, [__] RTBA. Thanks for the 22 months.
Appreciate it, Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Appreciate you.
If we uh guys, if we get any big donos, you let me know, okay?
We get any big donos. I Oh, I also failed to add an hour to the
stream at 254. 255. 2 hours 55. Let's go. All right, continuing
on. Is Teeny Tiny Tony one of yours? I'm laughing. He's all up
in Hutch's.
Uh, no. I think Teeny Tiny Tony doesn't like my content. I think
he doesn't like me or my content, I've heard. Although, that's
something people just say. I don't know if that's actually true.
He said he doesn't like the content. He comes into chat. Uh,
he likes Queman. He's a big Queen fan. Um, but he does come into
chat like if Queman's not online. No, he's a fan. Okay.
Um, I honestly it's totally um it's totally fine either way.
I got to watch I think him arguing with Yogi and humiliating
Yog one night. So, I I liked his I liked his arguments after
that. So, you know, anyway, I would take a link, by the way,
to the time stamp for when teenytiny Tony talked about to Hutch
and what it was about. That would be very interesting. I don't
know what they're talking about. It's probably unless it's about
Israel Palestine, which case I'm not sure I care.
>> So, it is what it is. Although, to be fair for the Ethan
sub, we didn't even have a bridger relationship. So, what are
you going to do? >> Whole lot of subs coming in for this
guy >> You probably know that Willie was reading off. It's
almost verbatim. The KF post that Doc is a girl. Yeah, I'm aware.
Same thing with um with a son on stream just reading down um
Blav Pose which is you know what
and apparently
Destiny reading in full a massive unhinged narrative only post.
Okay, a massive unhinged narrative only post about him and how
much of somebody hates him. Him reading that on stream in a way
that Doc's his girlfriend. Okay, doc full name Doces his girlfriend.
Uh he didn't care about it apparently. That's fine. But when
Hassan reads posts about Rose being 17 or some [__]
that's totally unhinged, guys. That's that's where the line's
got to be. He's reading factual information about my discretions.
Uh, no, that's Stark posting. Okay. When I read somebody's unhinged
post about me that doxes people, um, yeah. No, that's based actually.
I should be able to do that. >> Hey, listen. I see you.
I see the way you move. Okay. Plus one. Wow, Tamax, thanks for
the gifted subs, buddy. >> Oh, this is true, Gummy Verse.
Honestly, it just feels like exhausting to point it out every
single time. But yes, all of his responses are never addressing
his own conduct. They're always just, "What about this? What
about that? What about this person I've told you is evil?" I
think I talked about this in regards to like when I had my first
Fallout with Destiny, I realized that was like an easier way
to go. It's an easier way to like maintain that connection and
also like not have to deal with the fact that this guy's a total
piece of [__] right? Uh it was over like the some
of the Dan stuff, some of the anything else Patreon stuff. Um,
when I first had the had the first follow, I just started like
on Hassan a whole bunch. I got to maintain that audience. I didn't
have to like actually be close to this Destiny guy. And that's
easier, right? That's what all DJs do is they'll just look at
like, oh, Destiny, there's some some way I should criticize Destiny.
Uh, I'm going to go after Hassan. I'm going to go after Ethan.
I'm going to go after whoever is currently the evil person. JTO
in some cases. Okay. It's like uh it's so much easier to just
attack somebody than to, you know, hold somebody else to account.
to hold somebody you you get something from to account. And all
of these people get their worldview from Destiny. So,
Destiny, your issue is that politics is so virtue heavy that
if you do things like hook up with people over a decade younger,
you'll get attacked. Shouldn't you adjust a bit in that regard?
Um, so I'll say the same thing I think I already said at the
beginning of the stream, but I'll say over and over again. Um,
all of this drama is drug.
>> Uh-huh. I'm not even going to show the first message,
but I don't I don't believe this. up from old conversations.
It's the same thing getting recycled over and over and over again.
That's like nothing. None of this is from 2024. None of this
is from 2025. Like it's all just old recycled.
Uh also, I'm not running. It's not Nobody knew about it until
2024. So, I don't know why. How can you possibly say this, dude?
I killed a guy in 1995 and they found the body this year and
now it's just massive drama in my life. But it's like from I
I told him like, "Dude, this from 1995." Like, how the could
you Are you really digging up old drama from 20 years ago? 30
years ago,
really? That's kind of disgusting. It seems like you have to
be pretty obsessed with me to bring up drama from 30 years ago.
Okay, that's that's gross. Frankly, you should think about your
life. You need to get your [__] together if you're
going to drag up old dead drama from 30 years ago just cuz I
killed somebody you running for office. So, it's not like I'm
trying to be a politician or some [__]
And um
uh isn't that the whole Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Guys,
this is drama from before 2024/2025.
But you know what? It's not like I want to be a politician or
something. Destiny, can you think for a little second? Can we
just do a little introspection here and think about why did Destiny
say he was cutting out drama? Wasn't it literally to do like
the New York DG thing with Pisco to interview Democrats to become
a more stable and contributing political voice? Isn't that exactly
what you wanted to do? You wanted to run congressional campaigns.
You wanted to actually be a part of the political process. What
do you mean I don't want to do that? You literally were trying
to do that. Like this is insane cope. That's precisely what you
wanted to do.
And because you were a total piece of Yes. Uh, lots of this stuff
was from the previous year or two years previous, right? Lots
of the conduct that we found out about at the end of 2024 or
at the beginning of 2025 was from years before that, but we'd
only just found out about it and realize what a piece of you
are. >> Also, Trump is president. This guy's civily liable
for was banging prostitutes while his wife was at home taking
care of the newborn. >> Okay, if Trump can hit underage,
then destiny can. Okay, that's how it is. Okay, that's his role
model. It's Trump. That's the bar. Let's go pop on ARPGs like
Path of Exile or Diablo 2 3 4. They are the perfect background
game. Um the thing is is that ever since I started my Vancing
stuff, I don't have as much of an interest in like playing a
game while chatting with people or doing things cuz usually I
can focus on the conversation a bit better. Um like if I was
going to play a game, I think I would just play a game, which
I might. Maybe I'll do that soon. This guy's getting a lot of
subs rolling in. That's crazy. Now that we're two hours into
the stream, guys, I feel like comfortable pausing right here
and saying, "Guys, if you like the content, I want you to follow
me on every platform." Okay? Twitch X and the Discord. Okay?
Twitch.tv andx.com/jstlk
with an underscore.
discord.gg/jstlk.
Get in the Discord, guys. Be a part of the community. All right?
Oh, there's also tik tok.com/jstlk
official. All right.
If you want to take your support one step further, you can donate
monetarily. You can give me a couple bucks. All right, there's
a few ways you can do that. Exclamation point. Donate in the
chat. We'll give you the donation links. There's Kickbot. There
is Streamlabs. $3 minimum on Streamlabs. $2 minimum on Kickbot.
Kickbot's got the AI TTS voices. All right.
If you don't want to buy a TTS message, all right, you can sub.
Go ahead. Sub through Kick. Sub through Twitch. Twitch.tv/jalkk
if you want to give me a primer. Otherwise, go through kick.
If you just want to give money to stream, kick's the best way
to do that. Okay. Subs on kick are 955 split. money goes directly
into my bank account. So, gift subs, sub individually. Love individual
subs the most. And uh go ahead, donate, donate, donate. All every
dollar from all of the active donation stuff, all of the subs,
all the TTS stuff, all goes to more time on the stream. And if
you really, really, really like the content, there's also the
Patreon. patreon.com/JSDK.
Multiple tiers. Multiple tiers that you can join at. Okay. patreon.com/jstk.
Perks in the Discord. All right. Um, only two slots remaining
at G JWDP. Do not sign up for this unless you make six figures
a year at minimum. Cyberdrifter, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you very much, Cyberdrifter.
Appreciate it. Okay. Yeah, multiple tiers in the in the Patreon.
Even if you don't want to sign up for the Patreon, okay, at one
of the tiers, sign up for free just so you can get notifications
when stuff's going on. All right. Thank you guys very much for
listening to the shill. We'll get back to the content right now.
4 a.m. Aon 20 tier one subs. Damn.
These guys really love
These guys really do love their Aphibile King, don't they? Goddamn.
God
That's some crazy stuff. >> Oh, 20 subs, buddy. >> You
can spend Patreon money on broomstick sleeping bag curtains.
Okay,
I don't know what that story is. I Okay. Okay, dude. Um,
no, that was like a last second. That was a last second jerryrigged
thing because I couldn't sleep because it was bright out. Okay.
And I don't want room darkening curtains because if I get room
darkening curtains, then I'll just incentivize a bad sleep schedule.
If I don't have room darkening curtains, the sun will force me
to wake up. That's the thought process. Okay. So, I don't get
good room darkening curtains. All right. Never doubt man's ability
to innovate. By the way, never doubt it. It sounds like a the
story is um Cherry came here and saw that instead of having blinds
in my sorry I have blinds but instead of having curtains in my
bedroom I hung two clothes hangers and then I used a broomstick
and then I over that broomstick my own sleeping bag to cover
the window. Okay, but that was instead of having room darkening
blinds.
All
I have actual furniture everywhere else in the house. I I've
already explained I don't want to buy room darkening blinds.
I've explained why. Okay, I've explained myself plenty.
>> It is ridiculous.
Everything else is so nice in here. And there is a random There's
just two random plastic clothes hangers hanging on the sides
of the window with a broomstick going through them and a sleeping
bag.
A sleeping bag. And it's not it's it does not black out. You
can see the sun through the sleeping bag. I don't know what this
is. I have purchased blackout curtains and a curtain rod. Handling
it. >> That's true. How are you changing your voice like
that? Massive talent. Obviously. Obviously. Massive talent. Okay.
Anyway, I I don't I didn't want room darkening curtains cuz I
didn't want to incentivize a horrible sleep schedule. That's
all it is. That's That's what it is. Okay. That's what it is.
I have like I don't have It's not r/male living space. It's not
like I have furniture. I have like I have like plants. Okay.
Okay. I have like like uh browns, bronzes, and uh and plants.
Like not quite neutral colors like warm gold, gold, bronze, browns,
and like a lot of green plants all over the place. No, I have
a mattress. I have a box spring. I have a bed frame. I have end
tables. I have bedside tables. I have every piece of furniture
you expect a normal human being to have. Okay. Got all that.
Telling you. See? Poop my pants off. I didn't even do this even
though I know that's easier. I have a [__] I have
like a packing tape gun thing. I could have easily done this.
Yes, it is way more effective. I didn't want to do effective
cuz I wanted to not block out the sun. I wanted to like actually
get woken up by the sun, but just not quite as badly. That's
all. It was a calculated decision. Okay. I do have an air fryer
as well. Yes. Okay. Back to back to this guy. Let's focus on
the real evil here. Okay. It's not my >> Just curious.
Do you do therapy or do you have some system that helps cope
with this or you're just built different? I am build different
and I do do therapy with myself. Okay. >> So cool. So cool.
I I wonder how Eerite or Connor or Dan expected this guy to change.
Do you guys remember when Dan came on? I think I've got like
there was like a clip on Cherry's um
on Cher's Twitter. Let me go find it. You remember Dan being
like well you know Destiny's never going to do anything like
this again. He's never going to be like Listen, it's not going
to be the same because now Destiny's been punished. Okay. He
knows what punishment's like.
This is the one. Hold on. Let me listen to this. And I just wonder
without like therapy, without some way of like actually fixing
some of the underlying issues, how did they ever expect he was
going to like, I don't know, show any
repentance,
uh, like any contrition? How did they expect him to change, right,
in any way? Here's here's how Dan explained it. >> I'm
relying on the fact that, uh, you know what it was? I guess it
I would agree. Yeah, he was full of for all of this stuff, but
I'm relying on like the cat that stepped on the hot stove right
now and is going to never do it again. Like he's never really
gotten any punishment like this in the past. And uh
now he's going to be [__] I'm
Um I hope he gets from this but
uh because he
really bad he um with people's it's like no there's no there's
no element of like here's how we're going to change it and the
the if you guys remember the
the metaphor we used back then is like he's like basically an
alcoholic but his alcohol is like being a total piece of [__]
and hurting people and you're you're like basically saying like
I'm going to give this guy a couple bucks and hope he doesn't
you know get in another accident. I'm I'm going to pick him up
from the DUI. I'm going to give him a couple bucks and say, "Here's
your keys, buddy. You go nuts. Go nuts. What? You need 100 bucks,
200 bucks, and here's your keys, and you go hard." Okay. I think
now that you got arrested once, this is never going to happen
>> Uh trust in their consent that they put in them probably
gave a tremendous amount of people trust issues for the rest
of their life that they're going to have to figure out how the
they deal with. Um, you know, >> saying what punishment
I think is cuz even if nothing else happened moving forward,
like let's say Pixie and Cherry both got hit by a car tomorrow.
>> I think Destiny's giving people huge trust issues that
I don't even know how they're ever going to cope with. Uh, well,
you know, imagine if Pixie and Cherry got hit by a car tomorrow.
Good one. Good one. Good one.
I don't I don't see how I don't see I don't see how he won't
be punished still. Holy, holy,
dude. It'd be fun to go back and review like the early parts
of this and just see how correct we were about everything.
God, it feels good to be right.
God, it feels good. >> Okay, and then also I said,
um, okay, this is my last response to
this and then I'm done. Okay, I'm not talking about any of this
because literally none of this is none of this helping me publicly.
So, there's literally no point in doing this. Ty said he can't
respond to the lap score case of pixie. Fair enough if true.
I think he should probably get on stream with his legal counsel
and have them explain why I have any alleged CP since.
Fair enough if true. What? Dude, Willie Slackjaw just keeps
keeps proving everybody correct about him. Fair enough if true.
Has this guy stopped talking about all of his situations? He
literally sent you a that he then went on his stream and said
is actually not from the video. It's from when he sent that same
to a group chat of 10 people and he said it was from a video
she'd produced with a date on it that given her legal birth date.
Seems to imply she was a minor when it was and then he tells
you, "Oh, I can't I can't talk about it with the pixie legal
case." Really? Are you sure? Seems like you've been able to talk
about everything else. Doesn't seem like there's anything you're
not willing to talk about except except answering for your poor
actions or statements.
That's it. November is okay in this instance and legal. I'm not
seeing one lawyer agree with this for I don't know
you have to be to think that one that any lawyer would ever agree
to do this. Um the whole point like why would your lawyer ever
counsel you in a public setting in a public forum? Part of the
whole like benefit of patient client confidentiality or um not
patient uh lawyer uh client confidentiality is that these conversations
aren't accessible to the public. So the idea that
>> um actually I think you're basically telling everybody
I I believe this would be accessible not to the public but to
lawyers or sorry the like the law right if it's if every lawyer
is saying that this breaks the law and you're saying your lawyer
counseledled you to do it. It sounds like your privilege will
be pierced. No. Isn't that the only thing that pierces privilege
is indications that the lawyer is advising you to do illegal
things? You're saying that the lawyer is advising you to retain
possible seam. It sounds like that privilege is easily going
to be pierced and you've just given people the predicate for
it. Like this is another instance of he's still talking about
things. He's still making an of himself. He's he's literally
saying
I don't know. I think somebody should make Andrew Brettler aware
of some of these statements cuz it seems like people are saying
Andy B counsled this guy to retain a bunch of CSAM and not inform
the cops. And I I feel like Andy B wouldn't want that reputation.
Any law firm would agree. Oh, hey, let's do some legal counseling
in a public setting is beyond stupid. Number one. Number two,
the
to assume that I'm not like in Are you sure? What do you mean?
Am I sure? I'm I'm fairly certain that there I' I've watched
a couple legal people talk about this now. I'm fairly certain
there's no reason to that you could retain this without alerting
some authority. So either he is not telling us that he alerted
some authority pretty much immediately when when Solo told him,
right? Or
he's because the other option is he sorry there's three options
here. One, Andrew Breler actually did advise him to do this.
Two, he lied to Andy or something didn't inform him of this and
he's decided to retain it himself. Or wait, wait, two,
and it's like a table. There's there's both of those and then
whether or not it's legal to do so. But every lawyer I've seen
says no. Right. So if Andy actually advised him to do this and
he says, "Well, it's a privilege conversation." He would never
talk about it. It's like, "Okay, I think that would get pierced."
If he told you to do something that every other lawyer is saying
is illegal, I think there's there's a lot of reason to expect
that that privilege would be pierced.
But I I can't say that for sure. I'm not a I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not sure even a lawyer could say for sure.
He probably told Andy she was 18, so probably had no idea until
the last few days. Yeah, that's what I'm thinking is he just
lied lied to Andy B. Obviously. No, Riyle. I So obviously
you can't tell your lawyer, right? You don't tell your lawyer
that you have CSAM. You say, "Hypothetically, if this girl were
like underage, like how would I deal with that, right?
You can't tell them directly or else I'm pretty sure with like
the CESAM stuff, that's one of those things that would be almost
certainly mandatory to report. It would have to be, right? I
would I would I I can't imagine a le a lawyer or like a a bar
association that would not make that mandatory to report. Anyway,
we continue. Contact with anybody or having conversations about
things that are going on is also beyond.
Um but it's not but it's not it's not it's not it's not it's
not sorry. Hold on. I keep with this. Okay. This is not it's
not okay. This is intentional. I understand, like I said before,
I understand that people catch a lot of heat when they are associated
with me and so sometimes you have to do the performative like
oh my god like
is OBS recording? Uh I I got a report like I get it. Okay, but
don't pretend that you're like after some actual information
or actually because if anybody gave a [__] about
any of that at all, there would be a lot more questions for other
people involved. But listen, I get it. Okay, >> I'll be
honest.
I was just looking at DMs for like 15 seconds. cuz I'm rolling
it back. I'm so sorry I did that to you guys. I was looking at
something.
Okay, I got a report or something like I get it. Okay, but don't
pretend that you're like after some actual information or actually
because if anybody gave a [__] about any of that
at all. There would be a lot more questions for other people
involved. But listen, I get it. Okay, >> that was not anywhere
near enough time to go back. Hold on. He's helping me publicly,
so there's literally no point in doing this. Jess said he can't
respect the laughter's court case of Pixie. Fair enough if true.
I think you should probably get on stream with his legal counsel
and have them explain why having alleged CV since November is
okay in this instance and legal. I have not seen one lawyer agree
with this for I don't know how
you have to be to think that one that any lawyer would ever agree
to do this. Um the whole point like why would your lawyer ever
counsel you in a public setting in a public forum? Part of the
whole like benefit of patient client confidentiality or um not
patient uh lawyer uh client confidentiality is that these conversations
aren't accessible to the public. So the idea that any law firm
would agree oh hey let's do some legal counseling in a public
setting is beyond stupid. Number one
lawyer is not obligated to unless someone's life is in danger.
again I
okay maybe >> number two the
to assume that I'm not like in contact with anybody or having
conversations about things that are going on is also beyond no
we don't assume you like don't have lawyers or don't have contact
with lawyers we assume that you didn't tell the truth because
you're saying I retained these things right my lawyers advised
me to retain these things and pretty much everybody I've seen
has said oh no you should probably be reporting it almost immediately.
You need to immediately go to some authority, right? You can't
just hold your private stash of CSAM with no actual authority
knowing about it, right? You can't do that. That's crazy. >> But
it's not But it's not it's not it's not it's not it's not Sorry,
hold on. I keep over with this. Okay, this is not it's not Okay,
this is intentional. I understand, like I said before, I understand
that people catch a lot of heat when they are associated with
me and so sometimes you have to do the performative like, oh
my god, like
is OBS recording? Uh, I I I got a report. Like, I get it. Okay.
But don't pretend that you're like after some actual information
or actually because if anyone gave a [__] about any
of that at all, there would be a lot more questions for other
people involved. But listen, I get it. Okay. Oh, so what about
Solo? What about Solo, guys? You you guys actually care about
this? What about Solo? You think I should have said something?
What about Solo? Wait, the guy doing it? The guy The guy you're
claiming is like trafficking. Do we want him to report himself
or you want all of us to report Solo even though you have all
of the information on Solo that anyone has? You've got all of
that. We've got none of that.
And somehow we need to go find Solo and do something here. No,
you are the guy. You're the guy. You're the only guy.
>> Is that it? >> That's really it. I'm not not feeding
this not feeding this machine.
>> I don't think that's true. >> Eddie Logger,
>> I don't think that's true at all. I'll chat more
once my case ends, which is either in 1 month, 6 months, or 1
year,
I guess, whenever.
Yeah. Does Olivia uh have any political opinions? She seems culturally
socialist, but I would sort of say the same thing about someone
even Lwig or even extreme dad's uh humility lasted for like 12
hours, by the way.
Guess so.
Atriarch, I think most of his non-go have no idea. I don't know
the political positions of anybody on the H3 show. I just know
that they were all of them are in an awkward position because
>> this is the weird thing, isn't it, at Bagel and Coffee
that like literally Solo's the guy who leaked all of his revenge
and he thinks he's the trafficker, right? Destiny thinks Solo's
the trafficker of Rose, but he hasn't gone to the cops.
Gone like, "Hey, here's all the stuff."
Said they're putting a packet together for the DOJ. I've not
seen anything to suggest that he's gone to the cops like anywhere
yet.
Have you reported this to the DOJ? Have you reported this anywhere?
Or have you just retained all of this information and done nothing?
That seems crazy, doesn't it? Cuz obviously they did leftovers
of the son for a while. A lot of them are very um
I'm trying to think of a nicer word than like beholden or captured
by cuz that makes them sound like they're children. But like
there obviously there's a lot of um audience pressure, not even
from the H3 audience though, but from other people uh related.
Uh, Puggyups is a DJer, but Puggyups is a treasured member of
this community. Okay.
Puggyups is awesome. We love Puggyups.
I don't know if Puggyups hasn't been here for a while. Puggyups
is um they're they're here quite a bit. Yeah, they're here uh
like two days ago. They're usually here at the start of the stream,
but Puggyups is awesome.
>> So, they're kickod. Yeah, kick mod for Destiny. Kick
mod for me. >> Is there a limit to how much they can keep
dragging it with motions? Um, I have no clue. Well, no. I guess
there's no limit when you continue to violate court orders. Yes,
there will never be a limit when you continuously violate court
orders. Bro, of course there won't. Yeah, it turns out you could
like endlessly do crazy and continue to generate court orders
from the other side, but they're like, "Hey, your honor, I'd
like to direct your attention to him violating your court order.
Your honor, I'd like to direct your attention to him violating
your order again." Yes, they'll do that like infinitely cuz it
makes you look really bad.
Of course they will. >> Yes, there's not really. I think
at some point you can push for what? Like a rule >> Oh
god, I should do the shank thing. Dude, my voice has been kind
of going, but of course
of course they'll do that
thing or something. Um,
but the I mean it's you're right. Simple core. You can spam the
the docket as much as you want. I had a crazy woman ealock me
last year and it turned my life into a mini nightmare. It's time
for one of those girl groups like the >> Oh wait, yeah,
hold on. I think he actually doesn't he go and read his Kiwi
Farm thread in like 2 seconds. I could Oh, he's not done. He's
not done reading about this stuff at all. He just said he was
done and that was pretty much it, but it looks like he actually
does go on for quite a bit longer. So, >> he was total
BS, but when men are being accused of anything by women, the
burden to defend yourself, keep in mind, I'm not even being accused
of anything by a woman at all right now. Right. This might be
the first Well, actually, I don't know. This is the first time
that somebody tried to cancel somebody for somebody's alleged
age when the victim isn't even making any of the accusations.
It's just it's just other third parties. Jesus. Um I don't know.
Um I don't agree with all your BS, but you're not some beacon
of morality for me or anything. These people judging non-stop
are living in a diluted reality where they find their purpose
they desperately missing. Um maybe. Yeah. I don't know. I like
I wouldn't even care. Listen, you want to judge me for whatever
bull, that's fine. But it's just like the idea that um the idea
that like I'm some like pedophile seeker of like the whole Anna
drama was probably some of the most infamous woman drama stream
and she's like my age,
guys. The idea that I'm like a pedophile is totally crazy. I
[__] a woman of age.
I would actually I would say that most of the women I've [__]
have been of age.
Cue the cue the clip. Okay. Cue the clip from that four four
person, five person panel with him, Hos, and like all the women
where he's like, "Actually, most people who rape kids aren't
even
Cue that clip. Okay, cue that clip. I need that clip. Can we
cue that clip up? Where's that clip?
Someone get the clip. Okay, someone get the clip.
It's somewhere. Hold on. I I think it's in one of my threads
here. Give me a second. Give me a sec. Is it not here somewhere?
I feel like I just had it sitting here. Uh, it's not here. If
anyone knows where that clip is, though. >> So, what are
you gonna do?
One must imagine. Destiny happy. True. I love pushing the boulder
up the hill. God, we've still got so much content today. I can't
believe we did 3 hours on just this stream.
Jesus, I'm a master milker. Okay,
I should work on a dairy farm. I just milk the [__]
out of this content. Don't read too deep into that comment. What
the I don't know anything about this man, but he once decided
he wanted to debate me and I was harassed by his fans for months
while I said, "Who is that? What is happening? Who is this?
Did we harass this person for months? Did I miss the email on
that guys on the brigader on the brigade list? Rob, thanks for
25 subs." >> Okay, I'm going to move forward to wherever
he starts some >> with my report. >> Hold on. my
Friday afternoon coffee, okay, with my local FBI field office
>> Oh, this stuff again >> where they go through
the weekly reports >> cooling off because people are spam.
>> We should keep keep memeing. All right. Oh, this is
where he says thing about Dan. Hold on. >> Why is Dan backing
off? Because people are spam calling his wife's workplace and
harassing his family. Yeah, but hey,
>> That's the only reason. It really had nothing. I just
figured Dan probably would have been like kind of grossed out
by you starting a group chat and sending artifacts from CSAM,
purported CESAM, but CSAM very likely. Okay. To multiple people
in that group chat. I just assume Dan had some like heat for
that, but maybe not. Maybe Dan was totally cool with that. It's
weird for Destiny to say that, but good times. But that's okay.
We take a deep breath. Um.
Oh, no. Do you think audiences like H3s are more toxic? Do female
heavy audiences have more of a propensity to be No. Like I've
said a million times, I don't I think the H3's audience is like
significantly more normal than any audience over here in the
political streaming world. Uh just at least based on the little
bit that I've said. I think for
I'm really far outside of my comfort zone, okay? cuz I don't
dabble in these communities too much, but from like I don't even
want to associate them with like fem stuff, but like if if you
go to like female heavy audiences, and that doesn't mean just
female heavy audiences. So like H3s might might be majority female,
but that doesn't just mean like women heavy, but like women that
do like a lot of gossip or whatever. There's a certain um
there's a certain like
attitude where
it's so weird and hard to explain, but it'll be like a bunch
of like relatively
um modern feminist
like adjacent women, but they have the
attacks towards women that they don't like. Like that's usually
how I can tell like the fe.
So, this is just feeding way more into the stuff we talked about
earlier where he's trying to basically turn Ethan's snark narrative
against his own community, right? Trying to drive a wedge between
a lot of Ethan's community. He's going, "Oh, Ethan just read
from my like snark pages. Ethan's just like a snarker for me,
right? He's just trying to but that audience, that audience is
too smart and they're too cool and they're too awesome to ever
be fooled by just like snark like that." Unsourced snark. Okay.
Excuse me. That's kind of gross, isn't it?
It's uh it's just very transparent. It's very obvious silly audiences.
So, it would be like imagine going into some place and every
woman is like, "Oh, like this is why like her last two boyfriends
ditched her and why she probably got cheated on and uh this girl
is, you know, 35. Obviously, she's not married. You can tell
that she feels real bad." Blah blah. Like it or like it'll be
stuff where I'm reading like, "Okay, these are this is like a
women female audience." I don't I've never seen that from H3's
audience. Um
I don't know if um I don't know if they wrote the >> and
it will work. Uh, I don't think it'll work. Actually, I don't
think it'll work because unfortunately
eventually the evidence always comes out. Okay. The evidence
that Ethan was like abusing his kids or his kids were like in
a bad situation, it's not very strong. Okay. The the the jokes
about the gardian and stuff, that's not very strong. The evidence
for this is like
way stronger and it's a way worse allegation. Well, not if you
took the CPS call stuff like the Gardia stuff to it like maximum,
but
I don't know, man.
No, no, no. Even with that, Neoc, I know what you're talking
about. I'm saying even with that, it's still crazy to call CPS
for that. I'm sorry. It is still crazy to call CPS in that situation.
But
this one, this one's got a This one's got actual legs. Okay.
video of that. I never have any like idea of that. But from my
impression, it seems like uh how much do you think it frustrates
Destiny that the output he gets from DG chat continues to degrade
and degrade and he's watching his most important resource deteriorate?
Hard to say, but yes, that is the most important resource. That
is where everything comes from. Okay, that community was like
gold for him. They dig for him all the time. They they put together
documents for him. They email him about like what he should say,
how to look smart on certain issues. And it was his biggest resource.
And as that dwindles, his his own rhetoric dwindles significantly,
right? Like this guy's been relying on them for a long time.
I'm sure it frustrates him massively, but he also might have
enough of an ego that he doesn't really see it as much. Not totally
sure. The HB audience is significantly more normal. And I mean
that in a good way than all of the all of the politics audiences.
But again, like I stress, the annoying thing is that politics
it already draws like a more um
politics already draws a more toxic audience, but the um the
way that like people like now Hassan have just amplified it up
to 100 in terms of the weird gross like personal attacks and
digging because
Yeah, it was >> Oh, check stream chat for that clip. Okay,
give me >> has made it I think significantly worse. Yeah.
Or I shouldn't even say worse.
>> What about Hassan?
Blame it on Hassan
every time. Right.
Every time. How many times can you what about to Hassan?
Oh, this is another great point, dude.
I can't believe Destiny goes I can't believe Hassan I can't believe
Hassan's reading my Kiwi Farms page. Bro, you read R/ Destiny.
That is Hassan's Kiwi Farms page. Okay. I don't know if you realize
this. Desi's community is Hassan's snark community. All right.
Yes, that is the community that unhingedly follows Hassan, puts
all the about Hassan in there. Yes, you just run that community.
You're just mad that Hassan is is like actually matching energy.
That's what you're mad about. Worse, maybe this made it significantly
different basically. Yeah. Add Destiny. Ethan's crew is literally
just soy. It's fine, but they are the softest group of people.
It literally spills through the screen. Like I don't think I
like
guys I'm just going to show so much charity to everybody right
now. Oh my god. Like
you can say they're soy but like dude they're not like internet
warriors. They're like just they're like just normal people.
They're like regular guys. So calling them soy I mean you know
I know people in that audience really like individual members
of that crew. So I'm going to kind of give them like a blanket
amnesty from my community right now. I don't want you guys to
attack them. I don't really want anyone to attack them because
I'm hoping to attract a whole bunch of that audience. Okay, that's
what I'm looking for. So, I'm going to just grant a bunch of
fake charity to these people that I don't actually believe in.
Remember when I said AB was a totally loser like 30 minutes ago?
Remember when I talked to like about AB and how he was like total
and and like oh Hassan's just going to keep going after him?
Do you remember that? Well, actually, I'm changing that up now
and I want this to get clipped and we're going to put it on Twitter
and we're going to pretend that this is all I said about them.
Okay, we're going to pretend that that's all I did here. Saying
that Ethan's crew is soy is like being a bodybuilder and then
going to watch a movie and saying like, "God, these actors all
seem so weak. Like, I bet these guys couldn't I bet these guys
couldn't even bench a plate. I bet this guy couldn't do 10 pull-ups.
I bet this guy like it's like it's just not the way to evaluate
them or judge them. Like Ethan's crew is not supposed to be there."
Or the people involved with the podcast are supposed to be like
hardcore like debater. I'm the debater archetype. I'm going to
crush every like they're there to cover kind of like pop culture
news events, stuff going on in the YouTube world and to like
have fun and have a good time like like the um how does this
Can we can someone find the time stamp for like the AB segment
just a little while ago where he says like where he just totally
dumps on AB for not standing up against Assan. I understand that
you guys like to project like the craziness of my world or this
stream or whatever onto like every other environment, but believe
it or not, um, other other environments and other podcasts are
like have a significantly different demeanor, you know?
Yeah. And that's okay. It's okay that other podcasts are different.
That's okay. What is this? I'm going to cringe listening to this.
You're covering for people who show you for personal gain. Remember
when AB said that DGG hacked his account?
Yeah, you know what I am? and I'm going to regret it in the future.
I don't care. Okay, I rewatched the Batman movie. The Dark Knight
Rises. No, The Dark Knight L. Dude, really,
guys, I rewatched a movie and I realized I'm just like Batman.
I just realized that I am basically Batman. You know, lesser
known part of the DC comic book universe is the Batman arc. Okay,
Batman 17. Sorry. Batman for a 17-year-old. Okay, it's brand
new. It's really edgy. It's out there. And that's my favorite
Batman arc. And you could be like Batman, too. You just support
me no matter what. >> Last night, okay, and that's okay.
All right. I will just
>> When are you hunt me >> and the debate kid from
TikTok lining up for prep? Yeah, I thought we could do some funk
content around it considering that apparently Charlie Kirk is
like very scared of Dean
uh the the the Tik Tok uh liberal
>> Batman did get Batgirl pregnant. No way.
that really happen? But there's some part here where he starts
reading some post. Did I miss that? No, it's over here. Okay.
Okay. Hold on. >> And Dean himself
and so I I you know I might do a little collabo with him.
>> This one popped off. Oh, let's go. Okay. Hosanabi after
dark. Let's go. King is running for US Senate. Anti-Zion. When
are you with the debate kid from Tik Tok lining up for prep?
Yeah, I thought we could do some fun content around it considering
that apparently Charlie Kirk is like very scared of de >> How
do you think that feels when Hassan is like Dean uh Kirk is like
oh I'll I'll debate you Hassan no problem but uh but um but Deano
that's too much for me when Dean is like 20 years younger than
this guy. Yikes.
Yikes. I don't think you're familiar with the H3 podcast. They
cover a lot of heavy and complicated topics. It's not fun in
games. Yeah, sure. I'm not >> Dude, did you guys know that
Hassan's like not really a good debater? Do you guys know that?
Do you guys know Hassan's like not that good a debater?
um, yeah, Destiny, we did know that. Uh, Hassan talks about that.
Everybody talks about that. Hassan's not that good a debater.
Kind of sad that you handed him like every W possible over the
past 6 to 10 months. Kind of sad that you could have totally
owned this guy. You could have totally had him by the scruff
of his neck. You could have totally had him ruined, right? and
you just gave him every opportunity to take free W's from you.
I'll remind you guys, all he had to do was be like a little reasonable
with Pixie. And there's every chance that none of this stuff
comes out at all, right? If he's just reasonable with Pixie from
the beginning, if he doesn't decide that he's going to ego Pixie
for no reason, he just like offers her some reasonable amount
of money and walks off into the sunset, keeps doing his thing,
I feel like there's a chance nothing else comes out. Yeah. Like
I and he there's just no re-evaluation of what's happened, right?
How many times his ego is totally through this whole thing,
This this like uh this this Blav guy on Kiwi Farms, he thinks
I'm a a loser and like as a kid. Well, guess what, Blav? Here's
like pictures of Rose. Why don't you try to find her? You're
like on disability. 3 months later, that guy finds that guy finds
her with those
It's like, I can't believe you guys are looking at information
from Kiwi Farms right now. That's really disgusting.
Uh-huh. Yeah, our conduct is the thing that's disgusting here
for sure. Trying to say that it's all joke sort of, but I'm saying
that the mood is significantly lighter. At least that's my impression.
I could be wrong. I don't watch anything. I don't watch any online
content. I'm going to be honest. I'm the anti-consumer. I hate
watching everything. I can't watch
>> Can someone watch time this guy right now? We get some
watch times on this guy. Like I I'm sorry.
You know what he's saying, right? He has watched more of my content
than anyone else's. That's just facts. Okay, we all know that's
true. He constantly references it. He
He constantly references it. He constantly has to talk about
it in his chat. He's posting clips. He gets mad about time stamps
and clips all the time. He's just a big fan.
He's just calling your content serious content. I guess so. I
guess so. 5 minutes. >> I can't listen to >> that.
By the way, that only starts counting if they type in chat. So,
doesn't count all the lurking time. >> Podcasts. All right.
I hate all consuming all online content. Even when I was a pro
gamer, I hated watching pro games. I just wanted to go and play
games. I didn't even like sitting there watching it. Um, so I'm
sure they I know they do cover serious stuff occasionally. But
>> what is this? Ethan throws it back to the time he exposed
Vos and Destiny defended him. Lots of folks dying on Loy Hill
today. I'm reminded of when Now to this one. I just want to see
the Queenman reaction. Okay. Oh no. Ethan's on the other side
of this. Queen Queenman will stand with Bosch. His boy Vosch
on this one. Okay. And the Vosch lolly happened. Destiny defended
Vosch. And I remember exactly what he said. Yes. Because I thought
it was so >> This happened exactly like this. Yeah, this
happened exactly like this. >> Outrageous. He said, "How
old is the girl in the drawing? You mean how old is the drawing?
It's drawing. Who cares?"
I'm sure you've got the Where's the greatest hits? I don't care.
All right, guys. I don't care. Okay, I just spent an hour talking
about this. I don't care. I'm done. I'll never reference it again.
I'm on to my legal cases. When my legal cases are finished in
2 years and 3 years and 10 years, you guys, I'll totally tell
you guys what happened here, okay? Like, just message me in like
10 years and I'll tell you what was actually going on here. It'll
be crazy. Okay? Or we could wait, you know, 90 seconds and get
the next piece of like drama content from this guy. >> Chances
on Charlie Cook. Uh, sorry, Cook. I just read up
>> uh Nope. Soap box, you actually heard that exactly incorrect.
He says, "I could steal manand this and help Vos, but I see no
reason to." And then he steelman it to help Vos. You just didn't
remember the rest of it. Literally, the other the next like 30
seconds of that clip is him saying, "It's just a drawing. Who
cares? I don't think they're separated by more than 30 >> Is
Destiny Cook uh Chance Charlie Kirk debating it? Charlie Kirk
will never willingly debate me, which is a smart decision from
him. >> Are you serious, bro? Are you serious? Bro, I'm
not even going to say the end word you
black guy. >> This has to be fake, right?
>> It's 100% fake. Um employee got like customer service
industry and the employment industry would be off back. I just
don't feel like um that I have to there's a piece of advice I
give to everybody and you just have to remember this piece of
advice and I have to remember it and sometimes even I forget
is that sometimes is crazy. it usually it resolves in a few days
or in a couple weeks just depends on what it is. Uh there's a
reason why I've outlasted all of my critics. Um and I think significantly
compromising what I do or who I am to start going hard on people.
Uh and then losing whatever charitability I
told you guys. I told you guys this was going to be a rage bait
stream. I said it was going to be a rage bait stream. This is
just him. This is him speaking like directly to me. I think
right? Like he is just saying the opposite of what reality is
right here.
I don't know. >> And I think significantly compromised.
Usually it resolves in a few days or in a couple weeks. Just
depends on what it is. Uh there's a reason why I've outlasted
all of my critics. It's like somebody who like keeps stabbing
you in the back with a pencil and they're like, "Guys, the most
up thing." Okay, there's a reason that I'm so well respected
around these parts around this classroom, okay? It's because
I've never stabbed somebody with a pencil before. I would never
do anything like that. It's absolutely disgusting the way other
people others with pencils. I don't do that. Okay, this is this
is unironically what he's doing here. And it's like it's honestly
it can't even get me upset. It's just funny. Okay.
Um, and I think significantly compromising
what I do or who I am to start going hard on people. Uh, and
then losing whatever charitability I I guess I provide for people.
I Yeah, it's not good. I don't want to turn into that.
what want to turn guys? We never want to compromise our beliefs
to go hard on people. We not We never want to compromise what
we believe, our principles to go hard on people, change who we
are, and not give them the charity that we Uh-huh.
Uh uhhuh.
Like the principle that uh that like information is information
and pulling it from Kiwi Farms doesn't change it. Uh like what
what information exactly? Who believes this anymore? Dude, there's
no way anyone could believe this. Dude, what about the whole
principle of like I need to watch clips? I need to guys, the
best way to know a creator is lying is when they won't pull up
any clips to actually like fight back against the
to fight back against the exact
quotes. They won't even show the other creator. They'll just
like summarize their position. What happened to that? I don't
stream in 30 second segments. Yeah, what happened to all these
principles? They all went away. They all flew away. I just have
to like I internalize that and it means something to me and it's
not something for other people. So when people ask me like like
how are you charitable to people even if they're like get weird
or backstab you or do the Ethan snarker the reason is because
there is a personal payoff for me to act in accordance with those
beliefs and it's not about necessarily getting any type of mutual
uh grace or charity in return. It's you intentionally trying
to farm their audience to show that you're the bigger person.
Fortunately you also just were revealed to have been like the
with the minor is already bad, right? That's already bad. Maybe
there's a chance you could come back. Maybe there's some universe
where maybe that
I don't know. I hope not, but like maybe
But like, dude, we just found out you just confessed to creating
a group chat to try to find that same minor and that you sent
artifacts of the the taken when she was a teenager. Sorry, when
she was she would have been a teenager either way. when she was
a minor. You sent those artifacts to that same group chat implicating
all of these other people
implicating by the way like everybody who didn't. And you by
the way you did this when there was every reason to believe that
there would be holds on your Discord data.
That's how bad the decision-m was. I'm not even I'm not even
approaching this from like a moral place. If you know that you're
about to have lawsuits coming that say, "Hey, Discord, you need
to retain this guy's logs." And then you start a group chat.
You start a group chat where you start sending possible seam.
What could possibly compel you to do this
to make these decisions? Like just think about that. He he got
threatened, okay? Or sorry, he had these leaks coming. There
was every reason to believe he could be getting sued. There's
every reason to believe uh the solo guy had said she was a minor.
There's every reason to believe that law enforcement could end
up looking at his Discord.
and he still started a group chat to try to find her. That's
insane.
He admitted to this on stream. He's a white hat investigator.
You guys don't understand. I dude, it's it's baffling. >> Like
that's just Yeah, there has to be like a personal payoff. Somebody
messaged me the other day. I don't even remember this. Um like
when Chud logic was full on some minor chick who lied about her
age and I had um Yeah, I remember. Yeah. Jesus. the Yeah, but
the I think when I put my neck out in those situations, I'm not
putting my neck out for some kind of pay. >> Okay, so apparently,
yes, uh he's going to bring up the Chud situation. Chud did get
lied to about this person's age, right? Chud did get lied to
about this person's age. I don't know if they uh if Chud received
CSAM
and I'm pretty sure
I I feel like that's there's a no way there. I feel like that
didn't happen. Okay. But in addition, I'm pretty sure he didn't
also retransmit that same cam. I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I think I would have heard about that. Okay.
Did Chud I think there was stuff that was like flirting. I don't
It got inappropriate. Okay. It got inappropriate,
I think. But here's the thing. I haven't looked deeply into it.
I think he talked about penetrating their shyness. Okay. Penetrating
their shyness.
And there were there's some stuff. Okay. There's some stuff there.
It was a little weird. It was a little weird. It got a little
weird,
but it's not the same. And to try to equate these things to try
to equate these things is a little crazy in my opinion. It is
gross. I do believe he thinks that he should be, you know, he
doesn't mind when people make fun of him for it as far as I know.
But it was gross and it it was what it was. Okay. Payback or
for some kind of like reciprocity or uh loyalness or whatever.
It's just it's probably a good thing to do. Yeah. >> J,
did you know 95% of men have said a minor is an adult? I didn't
know that. Wow, that kind of makes what Destiny did seem kind
of okay given that totally real fact that exists.
Wow, I didn't know that. Okay, where is he going to start reading
this post? I don't think this post is like serious that he starts
reading. Now we go past this whatever this is.
>> You sent some Oh, look. It's a Guys, I thought it was
Ron to read. Is that Kiwi? Is that Kiwi Farms? I thought only
Starkers read this. I thought only snarkers read Kiwi Farms.
Already got 73 views. I thought only snarkers read Kiwi
What? What? Hi everyone. Long time l first time poster. Given
the allegations that have come to light in the past couple days
involving Destiny, I thought it might be worthwhile to share
my story. I will be a bit vague as I believe Destiny might sell
the required permission to do return. Justin predicts I'm not
located in the US. About a decade ago, I did a lot of work events
planning with universities, esports events, and hospitality venues.
A new bar that had financial backing from a rather large hospitality
group had opened in my city. The bar is located near three major
universities and it was quite heavily advertised when it was
launched. It had a large emphasis on being gaming themed, hosting
esports and being an alternative to bars that show traditional
ball sports.
And I wonder where this is going to go. To be honest, I have
no idea where this is going. I assume it's like a totally unhinged
unsourced allegation because if it had anything if it was like
relevant, I'm sure he would not be pulling it up at all. Right.
He needs to bring up somebody like totally having something with
no evidence. Kind of like the Odashar thing, right? And he needs
to pull that up. I'm guessing very late 2015, I was approached
to make an event within a budget that could be used to launch
the bar. One of the events that I had planned was to give some
prominent online figures who would give a presentation on a topic
that was relevant to internet culture. And then they would compete
against regular patrons in games like Mario Kart and other party
games where after 11 p.m. it would turn into a nightclub and
everyone socializes. That's was one of the prominent figures
uh that it was suggested by someone as part of the planning committee
as this was around the time when live streaming really broke
into the mainstream. I remember the Dota International and SC2
being quite popular at the time as well as the 2016 US elections.
University campus rhetoric was also accelerating quite fast around
this time too.
The idea was that Destiny at the time was the most streamed person
in the world. I reached out to Destiny via company email and
actually got a response reasonably quickly. We had two or three
voice calls to come to terms about logistics and fees.
when it So, first of all, you have your timelines wrong. Um,
by late 2015, I think I would have already transitioned out of
Starcraft and I think that League was like way bigger at this
point. I don't think anybody was talking about Starcraft very
seriously. Okay, that's okay. 20
>> dude, I'm uh >> I reached out to Destiny
and actually got a response quickly. We had two or three voice
calls to come to terms about logistics and fees. When it came
to planning Destiny's travel to my country, I engaged with our
partner immigration agent. The immigration agent had a template
on a company letter head that we send to our talent which asks
them information that might be relevant to bringing them to the
country. The question asks very basic questions about dietary
requirements, medical issues, travel insurance, emergency conduct
information, and criminal record for why would you ever Why would
criminal record even be on here?
Okay. Travel insurance.
Oh, I wonder if this guy is Oh, he must be European. I think
travel insurance is a big thing for European.
Wasn't that obvious from earlier? I thought that was really obvious
that um it was earlier from something they said it was obvious
it was a European thing. >> I've never heard of Americans
talk about it, but I know like Molina and stuff would bring it
up um and her dad was bringing on it. Or maybe maybe other Americans
haven't. I've just never heard of it. But um >> who cares?
Can you get to the point?
>> Oh, you can tell the European cuz they've done like
six paragraphs of context that nobody gives a about. Say what
the he did. Shut the up. This is the worst told story I've ever
seen. I It's the worst told story I've ever
Maybe not quite, but like yeah, it was easy. I'm just saying
that like who needed to know all of these things? Why were all
of these things important? Say what he did first and then add
context. Oh, sure. Yeah, but I don't know how much this is real,
not real, but for my country, these are questions which are asked
by police on entry and they entry to the country. Certain visas
don't allow entry if you have declared certain issues. I don't
think I've
ever answered a question about criminally entering the E. I don't
think this has ever happened before, but okay. Um, also I don't
think they ever applied for a visa either. Although I think it's
like when they stamp you, it's like considered like a visa automatically
when you go in. Um, an example will be someone coming to entertainment
visa if they have a declared medical condition without proven
travel insurance. Yeah, this never before. Um, the biggest issue
we are concerned about is a criminal history heavily targeted
on entry and most refuse entry. I've never heard of that in my
entire life. Unless you murder someone, but even that I don't
think they do. I've never heard of like a criminal background
check. Um, traveling from the US to Europe. Unless maybe you're
applying for a specific visa to stay for more than 90 days or
something maybe. I don't know. Once I receive the package from
my partner agent complete, he completely
let me go and check out. What was I looking for? What was I looking
for? Destiny responds to the allegations.
Is this just is I I was looking at LSF threads here for a second.
This just a This is just the Ethan tweet, right? Honestly, I'm
debating a prosecutor. Ethan snarking while crying about Hassan's
community snarking is truly pathetic,
bro. This subreddit is like so overrun, so astroturfed. It's
crazy. It's like the most astroturfed place on planet Earth right
now. It's nuts. And ex Destiny orers will still say that Destiny
and Ethan, two people who have never met, are besties. No, never,
Oh, I just upvoted somebody accidentally. I don't want that.
I don't want that. No, thank you. No thank you.
Anyway, okay, I think we're I think we're done with all that
stuff. We're finally done. Thank god. Thank god. Thank god.
Finally over. Finally over. Unless I haven't clicked all my links
in my docket. Oh, we didn't look at all the Ethan messages. Okay,
Destiny also didn't look at all the Ethan messages. Just give
me a second.
So, I'll look at all the ETH messages in order here. Check them
out. Not those ones. Not those ones. These ones. Okay. Destiny
fans, here's the issue. You say nobody knows for sure if she
was 17 when the nudes were exchanged. The fact that Destiny even
put himself in this position is bad. He's 33 and she was 17 or
18. How can anyone defend this?
Uh, so, well, for one, there's no actual hard evidence she was
actually 17. For two, his lawyer literally told him not to because
if she is 17 in those videos, then that's destroying evidence.
And three. So this person will just repeat what Destiny says
with no internal monologue. This is a robot. This is not a human
being. You shouldn't even respond to these people is not a human.
Not a human. Not a human. Not a human. If all you can do is repeat
what Destiny has told you, you are not human.
Okay.
Uh, one, you're saying he knew it might have been a minor and
his lawyer told him to preserve the images to protect himself,
which means he knew there was a chance it was CP. But two, his
lawyer absolutely did not tell him to hold on to potential CP.
Lol. That never happened unless his lawyer is Jared Fogle. Possessing
CP is a crime. Period. Unless you're doing a federal a fed doing
an investigation. There's no such thing as hanging on to CP.
Just in this case, it's just not a thing. I believe one of the
um affirmative defenses, okay, that you can raise if you're accused
of or charged with possessing CP is one of the affirmative defenses
is I took this to the authorities immediately and I can prove
that. That is one of the ways you can defend yourself from that
charge in many places. Lots of folks dying on Wally Hill. We've
watched this one. We read this one, the Wally Hill one.
Destiny literally told Willie Mack on the record that he has
his this material unamiguously. Full confession. And why the
is he accepting nudes from people so young they live with their
parents, have braces, and do homework? That anyone defending
Destiny has lost. And I would be a total hypocrite not to call
him out entirely. This is something I've always passionately
stood against, and what Destiny has done is pretty much as bad
as anything I've seen. Period. I have no desire to further litigate
this. if you have any. Uh, so Ethan is being a total here. Ethan
is actually so bad at this. He needs to shut the up and sit the
down. Okay? Because unfortunately
for him, this precise argument worked 8 months ago, 9 months
ago. This is the exact argument you could have had 9 months ago,
and you took talking points from this guy for 9 months instead.
Shut the up. Sit the down. Sit this one out. You're not the guy
who can make these criticisms, okay? This is the exact thing
that was there 9 months ago, right? And why is he even accepting
news from people so young they live with their parents, have
braces, and do
Uh, we knew that. We knew that when this leaked, it's nuts
to throw this out there. Okay.
Anyone defending Destiny has lost and I would be a total hypocrite
not to call him out entirely. This is something I've always passionately,
by the way, I'm not even saying you have to call him out for
this. I'm saying Ethan is calling him out for this and saying
he has to call this out. But you didn't call it out for months,
Ethan. Unless Ethan didn't know. Are you telling me that all
of those supposed Hassan fans around him, right?
The irony. Oh, we've got a 20 IQ person in chat. The irony of
Jaytock saying this is hilarious. Uh, when am I sitting here
going, "Oh, Destiny texted somebody who did this. Um, he's he's
I would always call him out. I have a principal against this."
You can't text somebody who has braces. You can't text somebody
who's young enough to be doing homework. You can't text somebody
who lives with their parents.
That's not the that's not the criticism, obviously. And making
that criticism is
and that is the point I am making.
Do you understand the difference? This is something I've always
passionately stood against, but not for any of the previous nine
months that this has been obvious in public.
And what Destiny has done is pretty much as bad as anything I've
seen. Period. I have no desire to further litigate this. If you
have any inkling of desire to defend Destiny, I can promise you
this is not the right community for you. Sorry, you can all leave.
I'm right.
We knew more,
bro. Are you serious? Are you telling me this community that
watches Hassan all the time, Hassan was referencing this [__]
Everybody was referencing this?
Are you telling me that these logs weren't all over Twitter 8
months ago? Everybody knew that these things happened. They just
didn't know for sure that she was a minor. So to say that only
that only the facts that were in those logs means you have to
call Destiny. You have to totally disassociate from him, anyone
around him at all, that's insane.
Isn't that insane? I like I don't care if he wants to claim ignorance,
right?
Think he only covered Pixie in my statements initially. I don't
care if he wants to claim ignorance. I don't believe he's ignorant.
I don't believe you be ignorant while while associating with
Dan. Literally, Dan is his business partner. Dan actually has
the redact.dev button on Ethan's podcast. They talk
You're telling me he's going to make that association, take all
of the talking points from DG, and do zero due
Really? really.
He's not going to ask Dan like, "Hey, is there any truth to any
of this stuff?" He just didn't want to call Destiny out cuz Destiny
was useful to him
and probably cuz Destiny was Dan's friend. Anyway, I I just think
I think that's just silly cuz this has been information that's
been out there. He called Destiny out a lot for the things he
just said are totally unforgivable to himself.
I just don't believe it. But if you want to if you want to keep
saying that, maybe Oh [__] Did my stream Oh god.
Hold on. Keep typing in chat. Somebody type in chat. Did this
just break? Oh, no. It's fine. It's back. Uh, let's see here.
I wouldn't be shocked if Ethan just have done zero due diligence,
but he looked into all these situations and they're a drama channel.
There are a bunch of people around Ethan who would have known
this exact thing happened, right? They don't know. FF.
I don't think we're effing, bro. That's you. That's all you,
buddy. Yeah. Nobody else is effing. Tell Tell this guy nobody
else is effing. Well, anyway, hold on. I I think people here
don't understand the point I'm making. They just don't get it.
Give me a second. I'll pull this back up so you can understand.
I've never once said that this is enough to say that like
that anyone defending Destiny has lost and I would be a total
hypocrite to not call him out entirely. This is something I've
always passionately stood against. It's like, dude, all of these
facts, if you're saying you've always passionately stood against
them, these facts have been out there forever. The thing that
changed, the only thing that has changed is knowing the age of
Rose.
But you're not making that argument. You're making you're making
the argument regardless of her age. I need to call you out now,
right? But I'm telling you that all of this information has been
out there for a long time. So, by his own standard, he's b he's
like full of [__] I'm just saying by his own standard,
he's full of here. I hope you guys understand. I'm not saying
that's my standard that you like have to always call this out.
This is like the most unforgivable thing in the world. Although,
I will say there's a lot of red flags there. Add it into a couple
other things. There are a lot of a lot of red flags there that
you can criticize Destiny for. Anyway, okay. Let's keep uh let's
keep trucking along here. I think we go to the legal mindset
video now, right?
Yes. Yes.
Oh, no. Wait, I lied. Not the legal mindset video.
I just I want to watch this real quick as a treat for myself.
Okay, >> let's go back. We'll watch this. >> As a
treat for myself.
Just as a treat for myself. Just a little treat for myself. Okay.
Oh, Twitch just really, dude. It's like Twitch and Kick both
do this thing where they crash. >> Oh. Let's go back. We'll
watch this. Right. So, this is this is >> little treat
to myself. I'm going to watch the Asmin Gold react to the Willie
thing just real quick. >> Crazy [__] Like,
apparently this happened yesterday. This is getting a lot more
serious than I thought it was going to be. Like yesterday, I
was not as sure, but like things are getting pretty serious.
Listen to this. >> It's because he continued to write,
"I didn't know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording blah
blah blah." And then he shows me his the top of a video clip
and says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls. It's
absolutely insane to think about him doing all of this if she
was 17. Well, this >> So, um, Legal Mindset
made a comment about this.
>> Oh, that's who we're going to watch in just a little
bit. >> Ly Mindset himself.
Uh, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Stop. did a whole video on
it this morning. Yeah, as I said, I mean, this is this is his
recounting of it. So, you know, I've got no problem really looking
at this, but in terms of like the specifics of it, um, you know,
I'm not trying to get into it. You think you got the full context
in that 4 secondond clip or not? >> The sassy chatter is
coming said, so yeah, kind of like I I've read comments about
this topic. Yeah, I kind I kind of know what >> Yeah, I
kind of know what's going on. >> It's because he continued
to write. Do you think that the Do you think that the attorney
had full context when he made that post? What are you doing?
I like Destiny. I hope this isn't true.
>> I'm not going to make any judgment on whether I think
it's true or not. >> I have no idea. >> Well, he
kind of came out like immediately and said it probably was true.
Like basically all of it was true.
>> Know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording blah
blah blah. And then he shows me his on the top of a video clip
and says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls. That's
absolutely insane to think about him doing all of this if she
was 17. Well, this is insane to me. >> Um I believe that
they would have screen recorded Cyberdrifter and then sent it
to Destiny. I believe that would be the order of operations here.
Not 100% sure, but pretty sure >> because he's saying Rose's
boyfriend recorded CP while sending me a of the alleged CP. So
I asked to confirm if he just did that. If you were sending me
this, I'm guessing you still have that video. Destiny replies,
depends on why you're asking, but yes, I created copies of all
of our messages and everything when that court case started.
Just to be clear, he's admitting to having alleged CP downloaded
on his computer. He literally has the video open as I'm talking
to him. I go, bro, there's been >> Uh, so unfortunately,
you'd think that's bad, okay? But unfortunately for Destiny,
he admitted to something far worse. He said that's actually from
when we we were trying to find her. Okay. So, he says, "No, no,
no, no. That's not a from my VC media player. I have that stuff
like stored in a different hard drive. That's a from when I got
a group chat together and I sent them of this CCM and I just
pulled that from that chat." Okay. Like, jeez. I don't have it
like there anymore. I just But I did send it to all of these
guys who were trying to help me find that minor. >> Your
honor, he meant Cyberpunk.
Do not say that because then it's going to get people to want
me to play it again. Don't say that word.
>> At least since my last video that she was underage and
you still have potential CP. >> That was a big problem
is like you guys kept saying we want you know please do CP again
and I was like
>> am I crazy or is there like a thunderstorm in Asold's
background? Are you guys hearing that? Are you picking that up?
problem is like you guys kept saying we want, you know, please
do CP again and I was like,
do we know that the media D shared to the group chat wasn't censored?
I don't know that that matters, honey duckling.
That's claimed in the email and I believe there's some veracity,
some backing up to that email, right? But I I've never claimed
that it's uncensored. I've said he is he has created artifacts
of that and put it in that group chat. >> Stop saying that.
Stop saying that. Like cuz it was and you meant cyberpunk.
>> He continues, "I don't think I'm allowed to delete it.
Lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/destroying evidence."
And I reply, "Talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me." >> I
actually don't know the answer to that. I mean like cuz you are
supposed to preserve evidence whenever you're in a court case
and destroying evidence is bad, but also having that type of
evidence would be bad, too. I think that's an answer like that's
that's something that's like that's so complex. Like I don't
know the answer to that at all. this sort of stuff on their computer
without 100% knowing if they're supposed to. >> Debate.
Debate never changes. 10 years ago, I was watching Destiny claim
that isn't that big a deal. In 2025, I'm still watching Destiny
claim that
>> isn't that big a deal.
>> Do or not. Isn't that something you want to confirm?
I continued. You just let me know you have CP videos saved to
your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was underage.
You still have them. Do you see how this is? So now I've confirmed
that this guy has child on his computer. In my 8 years of reaching
out to people over allegations, I've never had anyone admit that
to me. The last message he sent me was one, I don't even know
100% of her age was legitimately less than 18 when these were
taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure if he has child on his
computer. He's just 99% sure. Got it. Two, I'm pretty sure I
have an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case.
I've talked about it with my lawyer.
>> Dude, the the number one does seem like particularly
bad.
I don't even know 100% of her ages. This is after, by the way,
the the the Kiwi Farms revelation that she was 17, right? This
is after that. And he says, I don't even know 100% of her. The
date is on the file. The date is from a day. It's screen recorded
before she's 18.
Okay. There's every reason to believe that she is a minor in
that. So, like, yes. I for a second I'm like, I wonder if Willie
is actually No, he is. Destiny is literally saying he's like,
I it's only like 99. It is only like 99,
>> right? Specifically with regards to the road. So, he
went from I don't know if I could delete this to my lawyer says
it's totally fine to keep. I don't know the law, but the idea
that his lawyer would tell him to hold on to CP for a civil case
just doesn't seem likely to me. I don't know. Law tube can figure
that out. Three, if something were to come out of this, I don't
know if I'd want to wipe everything and not have something to
turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political
creator is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about
to hear some
>> Oh no.
Okay. >> Hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever is actually
trafficking her or getting her to other dudes on video for him.
And if there was ever some kind of investigation into that, am
I hurting the chance of looking into him by deleting all of this
stuff? Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the CP is because of
a hypothetical criminal. >> Like, let's just pretend that
that hypothetical doesn't apply to every single on planet Earth,
right? Like every single could technically argue that they're
just holding on to that CP so the producer of that CP could be
effectively criminally prosecuted one day. Listen, I'm just holding
on to this because I knew that one day if you wanted to ever
go after this guy who recorded this this sick disgusting freak,
I was holding on to it in case the cops wanted it. That's all
I was doing with it, guys. That's it. That's all. That's all
we were doing here. Come >> Case that he is not pursuing
at all. Okay. Maybe these reasons are legally sound advice that
came from his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and just saying anything
to make it sound better to me.
>> Surprised no one has gone after Vosch for own for owning
CP.
Uh do you have proof that Vos own CP or are you just calling
like lollycon CP? Cuz obviously most places have very different
laws around drawn uh imagery of children versus actual imagery
of
Right? Lollcon in the US is not CP. I have problems with lollycon.
Okay.
But I'm not going to pretend that it is anything close to actual
CSAM.
That's insane. >> I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I just
know this guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 GB according
to him.
>> Focusing on the 60GB thing. Um
I I don't think this is actually an example of Willy's bad
reporting. Okay. I think Destiny left that pretty it seems pretty
obvious from what he's saying there that he is a I can understand
the misunderstanding. This is like one of the least bad versions
of Willy's bad reporting that's happened. Like this is something
that you could reasonably believe from the logs,
right?
Like Willy's done way worse reporting in general than this. But
yes, this ends up not being 60 gigs he has on his computer
>> to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he
doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong
somehow make Destiny in the right? It makes no sense. For all
he knows, her boyfriend could have been 17 as well. Dude, you
were 33. I reported this to the police and recorded my interactions
and calls with the detective. >> William, how you doing,
officer? Okay. >> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again.
>> Great question. >> Sure. Again,
>> screenshots or copies of the
Well, as I said, uh, you know, uh,
it's a pretty serious thing and, um, I I, you know, I don't want
to make a lot of comments on it or say anything, but, uh, yeah,
I have no idea. Passing the evidence to your lawyer on an external
hard drive would be a better option. I I mean, like, now that
somebody says that, it seems like that's the obvious common sense
better option. But, I mean, who the [__] knows, man?
Like, I I don't know. I have no idea. And I got to imagine that
that's a pretty easy Google search, chat, GPT, whatever you want
to do. Hey, I have come into I've only just recently come into
uh you know, materials that might be child abuse materials. I
want to report this to the authorities. How do I how do I do
so? How can I get this, you know, in somebody else's hands? I
feel like something tells you that almost immediately. No. >> So,
uh yeah, that's at least the way I see it. That's what I'm looking
at. That's what I think. And so, yeah. Are you going to defend
them, Stone? Why would I defend him? Why would I Why would I
defend or attack him?
>> People hate, but I wait at Jtock. People hate, but I
definitely understand the draw of Asmin. He's like the guy at
the bottom of the midweight meme, and DG is the Midwit, and I
am the genius. Okay, he's like the guy with the dented head.
Okay, I got you. >> I'm not a court of law. I don't have
the purview of >> And he planned on streaming today, but
of course she no showed.
Uh yeah, apparently >> the legal evidence that's provided
to >> I all I can say is if it it would just be weird to
me if she came out was like I have no connection to Destiny after
the after the display with America. Okay,
I
to them I don't know that I'm not an investigator. How could
I have any idea at all about this? This is not my job. Like that's
it. Like I I'm not going to do that. Beta chatter. Yes. >> No,
she can't stand by this. But now, Zuul, the issue is now there's
something she can't stand by that she's going to want to distance
from. But instead of instead of just distancing, she's probably
going to get really mad. Okay. Really, really mad at anybody
who goes, "Wait, weren't you like back with this guy? Weren't
you totally standing with this guy through all of these like
allegations and stuff? Did you actually like cut ties business-wise
with him? Did you like Well, uh, we'll see. Limbo Gang, you know,
we'll see.
And so this is Yeah, this is a legal issue. Exactly. Like that
that's literally all there is to it. And as I said, I I I know
people want me to look at it, but that's pretty much where we're
at. Karen's and insect out. Cracker Barrel is dying. That's right,
Let me see if I can find it. What is this? Um,
are we good? We had a little bit of a hiccup there.
So Cracker Barrel was having a bit of a bad time.
>> Oh god. I I I heard a little bit about this Crackle
Cracker Barrel woke stuff and I I had to I got to dip. Okay,
I got to dip. Want to bet NCS is a ride or die for Tiny. No,
I don't. Just needs to tell people she was working to get free
healthcare for all and defeat Trump. That is all that matters.
Yeah, that's why she was like, "You think Destiny's really smart,
right? You should come join our our our college our college age
debater movement." Okay, you're a woman. You're a woman. You're
college age. Can you come join our movement? Can you come be
a part of this movement with Destiny? Destiny is really smart.
You think Destiny's smart, right? I